and we're live we're officially live for
episode number 52
with a special guest adam's best friend
in the world ricky aguilar how are you
doing right now i'm doing good how about
you guys
very good very good to be here i was
saying you know there's a special bond
between the two of you guys
it's like step brothers it's like will
ferrell john c reilly over here
yeah you know the scene where they're
like hitting yourselves with shovels and
killing each other and bearing each
other
yeah that's us ricky but in the end did
we just become best friends yes
yes we did that's just happened i think
it's it's important for us to say that
it was ricky's birthday yesterday so
happy birthday ricky i appreciate you
guys you know it for everybody that's uh
following uh the podcast right now once
you put ricky's instagram account below
go wish ricky
a happy birthday give him a follow and
wish him a happy birthday on his
instagram
how young how young are you 33 33 30
same age as jesus bro
it's a magical age yes it is it's
imagine what you're doing when you were
33 ppd
i was where were you i was running uh
the company and i had no life i was
going 100
100 hours a week non-stop 33
nothing 33
42 difference nothing's really true
where do you see our friend ricky when
he's your age where do you give me the
vision
ten years from now nine years i think
ricky's one of those guys that he can be
a generational leader to impact the
latino community that's what i think
ricky can do because he is extremely
relatable he's not the guy that comes
with a degree
uh you know he didn't write schools not
like you know he's not a 3.8 gpa with
you and eight what what did adrian's
adrian was like well it was like a
student night award i mean
that guy's a brainiac well it wasn't
restricted that wasn't ricky he's
mexican as well bro
you'd like i went to i went to a uh
california funded uh
facility but it was not college that's
right
you did yeah well something tells me you
were working out in the yard uh quite
often
many years ago many funny stories the
other day i hold an emergency
zoom okay with our leaders okay no joke
look at him laughing
i'm not even kidding with you so i said
guys we gotta have a number we're doing
this video whatever we were doing the
other day
so everybody starts getting on getting
on getting on ricky gets on
except ricky doesn't have a shirt on i'm
like no joke no shirt on i'm like ricky
you okay he says yes i said what's going
on he says i'm getting a tattoo
so we had to wait back then yeah we had
to wait for ricky to wrap up
his artwork before we shot the video it
was a very
uh uh interesting um how many tattoos
you got
well i'm fully covered i'm my chest my
arms my legs yeah
my back when does it stop um
it probably won't okay but ricky do us
all a favor don't touch that beautiful
face bro no i won't
you put something on that face you're
not gonna pull off a tyson no i'm not
gonna die
what do you think about all these like
gen z hip hop like uh
trap wrappers with tattoos on the face
what do you say to these kids
you know i you know what's funny because
i actually thought about that i've been
i thought about it uh probably about a
month ago uh
i think that uh it's making them
millions of dollars right now
and then uh i'm thinking that what's
gonna end up happening later on on the
road and when they have their families
and they're grown
and they're just gonna remove them well
actually 50 cent removed some of his
tattoos
because he said face no you don't have
no no no no he removed because he said
businessmen don't have tattoos
right so he removed some of his tattoos
so i think that's what they're gonna end
up doing but you're doubling down you're
getting more yeah but i'm not gonna go
i for example i have my sleeves done
yeah but you can't my sleeves are
three-quarter sleeves so see they start
right there yeah
so anytime i could always be in business
attire and i'm never gonna not
you know i and i make it a point to not
go so you're like business in the front
right party in the back party in the
back there you go you go to hawaii
ricky walks around in hawaii without a
shirt on i mean it's just it's
in everywhere they probably think he's
samoan of some capacity yeah they uh
yeah yeah
it's uh it's funny it's funny i got bad
news for you bro i don't think you're
gonna be able to be buried in a jewish
cemetery probably not i don't think
that's gonna be able to happen because
you can't have tattoos
because you know how did you get yours
though what's the story with your tattoo
my tats
yeah oh man it's you know the
penitentiary bros in california
and you know some some rough stuff
happened nah the last person that's
going to get a tattoo is you yeah i
don't see you getting attacked i don't
i'm not
anti-tattoo i'm just not pro-tattoo you
know what i'm saying there's things
i'm not like i would never but i'm just
there's nothing
that has inspired me if i did get a
tattoo the one thing i thought about was
like the yin yang sign not like the yin
yang twins but the but leaning to the
left like
the the slightly left got it lightly
left got it yeah so the people are going
to try to paint me as a leftist
marxist communist well let me ask you a
question here's a crazy question
but we got a lot of different topics i
want to let me give the list and then
i'll ask a crazy question we go through
that so
we're going to have a good time
president trump dropped 298 98 spots
in forbes ranking according to uh the
magazine on world's billionaires kim
kardashian is a
officially a billionaire uh tim cook
says he doesn't expect to be running a
company for a decade from now meaning
he's not going to be there and his
strategy on dealing with biden
will be the same as dealing with trump
then we got a story about goldman sachs
predicting a big evolution in the way
bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies are regulated goldman
says it
dalio says it yellen your best friend
says it something's going on there with
krypton regulation
amazon is setting uh snapping up the
disused shopping malls and turning it
into fulfillment centers
amazon has a quota this is a great story
i can't wait to get get into this one
amazon has a quota for the number of
employees it would be happy to see leave
each year
employees say that's a big reason
amazon's culture
feels cutthroat the fact that they're
okay with people leaving yet some people
think it's cutthroat we're going to talk
about that
jp morgan chase ceo jamie dimon says
remote work can undermine the character
of a company
and lays out the bank's plan for the
future of the office he also says
economic boom fuel by deficit spending
vaccines because easily could easily run
into 2023.
tesla shorts china the cameras and the
cars are being turned off you know
china's freaking out with that
where is kamala two weeks since being
named border cesar
harris still hasn't visited
the border okay we're going to show you
a couple videos here that's going to be
absolutely difficult for you to watch if
you haven't already seen it
another story with putin putin signals
uh
signs a law allowing him to run for two
more terms as russian president it's a
tough law for him to
why would he sign a law like that you
know but he ended up passing it's a sexy
love for that guy
relocations from san francisco to texas
and florida jumped 30 to 46 percent in
2020.
uh in the constitution in close
consolations with partners and allies
around the world biden administration
will weigh 2022
beijing games for us caitlyn jenner
is reportedly considering a run for
california california governor
i don't want to know if you would vote
for caitlyn over newsom we're going to
talk about that
uh i don't know if you saw the lizard in
the store in thailand we'll talk about
that
anti-capitalism protester that takes a
beating fallen that was it's a very
difficult video to watch because it's
ripped
you're going to see this kid falling
yeah have you seen this or no his ribs
you're going to react to the ribs and
what happens after that had a rough
reaction yeah there was a reaction and
big
short one of my favorite guys yeah when
he talks i'd like to see what this guy
has to say
michael berry michael bury from the big
short quits
twitter disappointing his legion of
retail trader super fans
and pierce morgan to tucker trusting
marco is like believing pinocchio
pinocchio she's spinning future kings of
england
okay now you guys were having a debate
earlier yes
the debate was is there communist
country what would
help me out with that debate right there
if there's a country around the world
that's communistic or not yeah because
apparently
apparently if the name itself yeah uh
if they name themselves communist that's
not good enough for
for adam you know he says they're not a
communist even though it's what is the
republic
of the republic of china also known as
the ccp which is the party of china the
communist party of china so apparently
that's not enough
you know they don't identify as
communist even though they're communists
but let's define it actually because
let's define what is
one hundred percent communism what is
coming in should we should we look it up
for our followers yes
what is communication so communism the
definition of communism correct me wrong
was there's zero private ownership
zero everything is controlled by the
communism okay so the yes
a political theory derived from karl
marx advocating classworm leading to a
society in which all property is
publicly owned and each person works
and is paid according to their abilities
and needs so essentially
a classless society a hundred percent
tax
yeah okay now there is two sides to
communism right
one is control they tell you whatever to
do the other one is
on the business side economically uh
political right
china is politically yes communistic
economically
they're still allowing but at the same
time notice also what's happening with
china lately if you get a little too big
what are they doing to jack mazda yeah
you're getting a little too much voice
hey hey give us control back at this so
at any point the difference between
there and here is
they can at any point come and take
control of any business they want to you
can't say nothing about it
they can come in and do it at any time
but we've seen what they've been doing
with jack ma and everything they're
doing with the ant group
i totally agree i'll deal well but the
thing is that you said that communism
doesn't
venezuela did that there's actually
videos where there's a man
because i was speaking to vanessa right
here which is incredible part of the
valuetainment team
and and there's a video where where i
think is chavez
he's literally going he says what is
that oh they sell jewelry take it
what is that they do this take it that's
communism
that's that that's communism so to say
it doesn't exist
actually i think the champion oh
so to say that it doesn't exist oh i'll
get it
there it is okay so to say that it
doesn't exist it's the biggest guy we've
had in this chair maybe that's what's
going on you know it's crazy because
it's we've seen it in action as a matter
of fact the champions
of communism are from venezuela yeah
right i mean even
as well as an absolutely venezuela did
communism the right way
did they yes because they ruined the
country how do you get the richest
one of the richest countries in the
world with oil and literally ruin it
you know they have more money than they
have more oil than united states have
more oil than mexico
by the way mexico is uh to a certain
extent
have a socialist president right now
which is amlo pull out first and he's
uh and uh that's that's just insane you
know hold it up first the other side
ricky let's switch oh it's nice you
gotta be comfortable sounding good so
let's switch that because
that's the one that drops yeah okay so
let's use that that's much better i knew
it
i said all right ricky's going to make
his point on communism drop it low don't
worry
so look let's let's let's skip this part
let's look are either of us fans of
communism no
okay i was just simply saying that even
china but one of those things
one of us votes closer to communism than
the other that's for sure one of us
uh okay you want to go that route all
right one of us also votes
closer to queueing on then but we'll be
okay
no look one thing we should establish
from the get-go ricky let's do that
is i i like things in moderation
right if you're too far to the right
fringe i don't [ __ ] with you
if you're too far to the left fringe i
don't [ __ ] with you yeah i like to keep
things in between the 40s as if our
friend
tigram beckham is listening this is
something we talk about all the time
keep it between the 40s maybe you move
the ball a little bit to the left maybe
people to the right
anyone that's hanging on the goal post
like people who used to maybe be on this
show
right i can't get down with i'll call
out an aoc
just like i'll call out a uh
uh anyone on the right who's uh no
rubio's not all the way to the right
right
cruz isn't all the way to the right no
but uh who is all the way to the right
who is all the way to the right that i
mean that's a good question
who is actually all the way to the right
on the uh louis gomer from texas
louie gomez all the way to the right
he's very far no hold on hold on hold on
let's talk about who's far right that
actually has a voice
aoc has a voice omar has a voice listen
she's playing the game
bernie sanders he's playing the game
bernie sanders says he's playing the
game
who can't get mad at people from the
right i have a strong voice and a strong
opinion he's a radical
people are listened to you
my question is who is influential on the
right that is far right
influential not somebody some person
that you know that everybody on
watching us has to go look up you don't
have to look up aoc everybody knows who
aoc is
she's playing the game okay i get that
but what i'm getting what i'm getting at
is that who's so far radical fart right
that has a that's influential
who's far right that's influential it's
actually a very good question
who's very very far right a a i think uh
well-known figure that's on the that's
far is lindsey graham
far right lindsey graham no i don't
think he's very far is he a voice for
i think our friend donald trump had some
far right tendencies that
he is not very far right especially
socially
maybe um he's got some authoritarian
qualities
but he brings out people on the far
right so the authoritarian or you just
was speaking for the americans that are
tired of the bs
which one is this a little bit of both
well listen
by the way if you're watching this help
us out here who would you say is the
person that's who's the most
somebody said ben shapiro but he's not a
politician he's not a politician he
doesn't
i wouldn't say because he called that
trump this who would you put as far
right
politicians as a matter of fact ben
shapiro in 2019 or 820 was
the number one target of the all right
so you can't the alt right or the
alt-right
right isn't even far right they're
they're they're worse
that's even worse so that's what i'm
getting at ben shapiro was cr he didn't
even vote for trump in 2016. like a
david duke and not that he's uh
he's a he's uh but i'm kidding i'm
getting at the
sauces that you have to dig for those
people and they're not even big known
figures
the far left has a lot mitch mcconnell
i don't think i don't think any of these
are extremely far right by the way that
makes a very good point by the way
because if you think about it let's put
a chart right okay you got in let's just
put a chart here
okay i'm gonna put the line here in the
middle this is a
simple independent person okay
i'm gonna put the libertarian here okay
i'm gonna put the libertarian here i'm
gonna put the
the democrat say here okay
let's put socialist here okay
let's put communist here is that fair
yes okay let's put republican here
and then far right here
okay all right where would you say if we
say this is the independent
right in the middle okay libertarian we
got plenty of that right rand paul is
one of them
let's put rubio let's put cruz here yes
republican let's put trump here yes
okay i agreed where do you want to put
obama obama's here or you put him a
little bit here
uh i would put him in the middle between
democrat and socialist okay where do you
put biden
uh he's he's i i think he's a democrat i
think he plays a role
100 socially between socialists and
communists sanders
same thing who do you put over here
there's nobody big figures
like jeff sessions there yeah jeff
sessions who's that
we're talking about what
we're talking about people who have a
voice jeff sessions was does not have a
voice
there's nothing he's talking about my
grandmother and culture and coulter's
very far right yeah
okay so now let's see not a politician
she's right but not far right no got it
it's interesting
it's interesting to see well thank
goodness that there's not people
very very very far right that we can't
let me put into this i'm thankful of
that
you know what's crazy people think that
far right is we want our gun rights
right we were pro-life right no they're
pro-life pro-life
believing i always find it in liberty
but i'll kill you if you don't know
how is that how is that far right it's
crazy that
everything's got pulled so to the left
you can look at that regular
conservative values are not
far right you know like if it was some
type of nationalist type thing you know
it's insane so who's far right i'll tell
you it's so
it seems like loud far right trump's ear
what's this guy's name steve um
bannon steve bannon uh breitbart a
little bit but there was also the other
guy
the bald guy um jesus what's his name
the fact that you're thinking
immigration not a
yeah it's crazy let me explain to you
what i mean adam people
that are here think that this
is the middle and it's steven miller
steven miller people that are here
think that people are here are far right
i don't mean
between democrat and socialism
right it's not yeah so to them if you go
the line is
here independent yeah the left has
pushed the left the line
right where are you that this is where
they're at where are you on this chart
i'm 100
republican conservative aware on this
chart uh if if you had to
i'm right here this is where i'm at 100
percent where are you
that's another penny he's always said
that well i don't want to speak for
pounds i'm a registered independent but
i'm probably more here libertarian
because to me to me it's uh uh let me
see that go ahead
okay you're you're here you're saying
i'm right he's here yeah yeah somewhere
around here
on certain things but fiscally i'm
closer to now i don't think you're here
i think you're here i think you're to
the right of democrats i don't think i
think you're
your mansion i think that's exactly
that's who have i been saying for a year
that is like my favorite politics i
think that's who you are
i think that's who you are and in
certain areas i think you go
uh uh on the right but uh if it comes
down to this question i asked him the
other day asked him a question the other
day okay
i said as much as you hated trump okay
i gotta correct you never use the word
hate fair enough okay i don't
like as much as you dislike trump okay
and
you look at the character i said if
biden were to come out i heard you ask
them that
100 tax rate right okay would you still
have voted for biden you said
anyone that comes out with a 100 tax
rate i would not vote so then the
question would have become what
percentage would have been the one that
would have been the tipping point
well what is this are these marginal tax
rates is it over a certain amount i mean
what's going up
you're talking about well 100 000 more
right you're talking about wealth tax
corporate tax capital gains you're
talking about the state tax every tax
there isn't a tax there's no new tax
there is no tax that is not being taxed
everything is going to be well we
covered this last time taxes are the
lowest they've been in in history over
the last couple decades but the but the
point is
in the 40s 50s and 60s taxes were absurd
you know that's our under republicans
as well i did i did my monthly uh
private webinar
yesterday with the what do you call it
the the folks that are from around the
country say 40 different countries ceos
entrepreneurs that run their businesses
i said pay very very close attention to
taxes
so many times we work and we're not even
paying attention to taxes
right so many times we vote we don't pay
attention
to right taxes i agree to me taxes are
what's really going to hit everybody
right because it's logic right
emotion is i can't believe what he said
i can't believe what she said i can't
believe what he did i can't believe what
happened there this is not fair
that shouldn't be happening that's
emotion 90
of the time people vote emotionally yes
correct they don't vote
both logically i think taxes are
something people have to pay very close
attention to
because the direction these guys are
pitching could affect countries around
the world as well not just the u.s you
said that you were going to do
a uh board episode on taxes we got we
got a we've got
paper on top of paper with articles on
taxes that we're looking at right now
i'm not going to do it for the next
couple weeks but i'm going to be doing
it because
when i do a topic like that you've got
to talk about
you weren't even necessarily familiar
with and how high the taxes were
well no when i looked but when i went
back and looked at the numbers what
90 tax bracket was at two hundred
thousand dollars which is today's two
and a half million dollar year income
we're not talking about ninety percent
taxing twenty two hundred twenty
thousand dollar people
today they're talking about two and a
half million dollars of income
back in whatever year nobody would very
few people making right hollywood actors
reagan's yeah i feel so motivated but
the point i'm trying to make to you is
the fact that the number was a number
that touches
a small small percent i haven't paid
myself two and a half million dollars i
don't know
i don't pay myself 25 million dollars
salary these guys know how much i
get paid my cfo told these guys how much
i get paid right so the point is my
my money comes from a different place it
doesn't come from my salary
so mathematically it may seem like but
they were doing 90
tax and it's such a great but you know
if we can get to 90
we can get there again it doesn't work
that way you got to tell the full story
i want to go dig deep to do the full
story may require me to read a couple
books before i do this video because
uh uh that's that's a topic that i think
we need to pay very very close
unfortunately when you put a title taxes
guess how many people want to open it
and watch a tax video
right nobody wants to watch a tax video
i gotta almost put like
you know what do you call it the sex
drug and rock and roll
and taxes
i have a great idea yeah actually we
have to do something about it guys
actually thinking sex drugs rock and
roll and taxes
only certainties in life sex drug rock
and roll death and taxes there it is
let me ask our friend ricky uh you know
because this is
talking about being a moderate you know
i'm from florida
in florida we're very literally nice
exactly it is it is very nice
a very purple state meaning we can go
left we can go right we kind of keep
things in the middle we got
you know i went to college in
tallahassee which is in the northern
part of the panhandle
very more conservative part of the state
lived there for four years
down in miami a little more liberal but
a lot of cubans who are republican so
there's a mix of everything so we're not
too far left and you too too far right
so even tax wise there's no state income
tax i mean obviously this is a big topic
that we talk about right here there's no
state income tax there's no city tax
like in new york city or anything like
that
so for you that does very well for
yourself congratulations i say the
numbers i see the numbers
you could smile now happy birthday um
you live in california yes
you make a very high income i do at what
point is that taxes too much for you to
say you know what i can't deal with this
crap i'm paying
40 percent federal tax i'm paying 13.5
state tax i don't know if there's a tax
in bakersfield for just
no no but like this is legitimate
luckily it's uh we're very blessed that
kern county is a conservative county
uh it's it's a it's it's run by
conservatives you live in a very liberal
state
right yeah you're right uh you know
that's a that's a good question
um i i i don't i don't have i've never
experienced that
so i would i'd be very hypocritical for
me to hear sit here and give you the
answer to that
so what would someone to to what what
would be too much gotcha
right because that's something actually
you guys know that you know pat's my
business coach as well so i would that
was something i would consult like hey
what point is it time to go because he
has the experience in that so
but uh but i mean to even 40
i mean for people watching 40 that means
for every dollar you make they're taking
40 of it 40 cents
not necessarily true but go well what do
you think is it more it's marginal tax
brackets so your first
yeah but when you start 50 000
california yeah okay when you start
adding the state tax
yeah it's not marginal anymore effective
taxes of course
i mean you're talking about it's a whole
different ballgame but the point is you
pay a lot of taxes 100
but for some reason bro you've stayed
because
there's benefits you're getting right of
being in california whether that's
you know loving the the well right now
just it's just because that's
that's the majority not 95 percent of my
business is there well that's my point
there's
business there's economic there's i mean
you could go skiing uh
you know in the morning and then go on
the beach in the afternoon the whole
thing california is a beautiful state
but at what point is too is enough you
know
that's true it's a good question well i
mean the the
exact premise of what you're saying is
what
the california politicians use to say
yes nobody will ever leave because it's
like the whole
the way you kill a frog is what you
don't just go 212 degree temperature and
you put them in boiling water
slowly but surely you kill him he
doesn't know he's getting killed right
however
today there are a lot of people
including
you who are aware of what's going on and
are leaving yes since 1990 three and a
half million people have left the state
of california the percentage on the data
matter of fact since we're doing this
san francisco i was going to go into
immigration with kamala but let's go
into the
stats about i would like to touch on
that though for sure
don't worry about that bro we're going
there let's talk about relocation from
san francisco to texas yeah okay
specific city that they're talking about
is
san francisco san francisco to texas so
if we look at that on page number six
relocation from san francisco to texas
relocations from san francisco to texas
florida jumped between 32 to 46
and 2020 fox business the kobe 19
pandemic accelerated migration from the
u.s and 2020 compared to 2019 but
particularly
from large urban areas like san
francisco and new york to
sun belt metro cities like austin dallas
charlotte according to a study published
by the cbre real estate group
a summary of the study notes that many
of those who left these cities may
return once the pandemic is over
about 135 000 more people left
california in 2020 that moved in making
the third largest migration laws
in states history several large
california companies including oracle
hewlett-packard and
enterprise move their headquarters to
texas these are big companies by the way
yes to move your headquarters
to texas in 2020 and tesla's elon musk
moved to houston
in december tech executive including
palantir
chairman peter thiel and former paypal
executive
keith rabo recently moved to miami as
the city's mayor francis suarez attempts
to court the big tech players to south
florida suarez nicknamed
miami the capital of crypto and capital
of
capital in two separate tuesday tweets
we were at the event we were on the
other side when he said those things yes
ricky your thoughts uh it makes sense
i mean it makes sense for them why would
you want to stay in san francisco
uh where they literally have a map uh a
crap map
right where they have a map to where
people take the most traps in the city
and you so you could walk around it san
francisco yeah did you know that
kai go to san francisco crap map would
you bring us the map
it's a ship map it's you know it's a you
suffer so we're looking at right now
crap map
san francisco images of crap in san
francisco
look at the first one yeah it's a so
that's not true go to the second one
that shows you right there right where
were they
where the you know homeless are taking
unbelievable so they have a crap map
poop maps yeah this is ridiculous it's a
poop map like that
you didn't know they had a pet i had no
idea i had that's where you can go to
the gym
they're handing out needles wow for the
drug addicts so they don't pass
hiv to each other whatever the case may
be so but how far is this from silicon
valley
uh how many miles an hour an hour
give or take yeah i have a team up there
so tonight it's about an hour
give it to about about an hour hour and
a half maybe at the most depending on
traffic
so uh going back to going back what
you're saying is you're not surprised no
100 percent
well forget about what does it say 32
miles yeah san francisco silicon valley
32 miles yeah
so if i was driving in 15 minutes well
yeah especially that forward
so well traffic is about an hour but so
so to answer your question though
uh it doesn't surprise me first of all
because of the condition san francisco
used to be a beautiful it's still a
beautiful
city beautiful sights but when you live
there you're dealing with these things
it's different to go there for the day
and go with your family to live there
right that's number one and then on top
of that number two is when you're
dealing with uh you know
uh they they did a 15 hour at 15
if you run a business you can't afford
to pay people that plus workers complex
that plus have a profit
right so yeah it only makes sense that
people are living leaving san francisco
as a matter of fact
in bakersfield where i live in
bakersfield california we had a big
migration of people from san jose
san francisco uh vallejo salinas moved
on to bakersfield because that was well
the housing
rate was a lot cheaper and uh and it was
affordable to live so now i'm not
surprised they're moving to texas 100
makes sense if you live in california
you understand why they're moving by the
way give you a crazy statistic here
create this i was doing a video
yesterday about you know uh uh
moving to florida okay why i chose to
move to florida et cetera et cetera the
video actually gives you reasons
why i chose to move to florida it's
coming up probably what next tuesday to
come out right
one of the stats that's absolutely
staggering is the following how many
total homeless people you think we have
in america
total in all of america
yeah give me an over on though how many
total
first let me homeless you total u.s
population as of right now i think it's
330.
i was going to say 350. okay u.s
population
uh is at 3 328. in 2019 it was 328 let's
say it's 3 30.
okay okay at 3 30. how many homeless
people you think we have in america
i would say uh i'm gonna go with a
million patent
okay what do you say it is
two million okay so both of you are off
according to the
u.s department of housing and urban uh
uh development which is the hud
580 000 homeless people in america which
by the way you figured there's probably
more but that's the number that they
haven't registered right let's just say
580 000 people that are
homeless you know how many of that 580
is from california
160. give or take 160
one-fourth of it one-fourth a little
more than one-fourth of all the homeless
people
in america or from california or from
the state of california
do you know during the pandemic just in
the city of l.a
not california homelessness increased 20
000 people in the state in the city of
l.a 20 000 people in the city of
homelessness so are you surprised that
people are leaving california to move to
texas or florida are you
i mean how confident was suarez at the
dinner the other night
how confident was he got a shout out to
francis suarez mayor of miami the guy's
swaggy to begin with
i saw his picture oh my god the guy's a
supermodel he looks like a superman
we took a picture with him yeah yeah
i've interviewed him before
he's just a solid dude but when you're
when you're the mayor of miami you're
already in a strong position to begin
with you're the freaking mayor of miami
but now during the pandemic
everything that's been going on do you
know how much confidence and swag you
can develop
and play off face right now you can play
offense you can recruit you could say
listen what the hell are you doing in
california
he took a shot at cal uh new york no
problem saying look
they're they're already a mess and
they're trending in the wrong direction
come on down to florida i mean his
famous tweet was
to the big texas how can i help you yeah
how can i help yeah
and he is helping he like he said he
wants miami to be the capital of capital
so maybe
let me ask the question different ways
what is your name pat i'm sorry what is
it what way does it lean
uh center right center right center
right as a mayor it's not really too
much
somewhere says democrats somewhere says
conservative but i would put him as a
center
right guy okay i would put him as a
physical conservative
yeah that's the best way to put it but
but here's a question for you here's a
question for you here's a question for
you
say pandemic is over with pandemic is
over with everything's back to normal
everybody got their vaccines except
ricky and a couple other people right
let's just say the vaccines got
everybody being comfortable right except
for a small community
that's not going to get the vaccine shot
honestly 50 of republican men
unless if they force the passport id
there's going to be some
people getting arrested because some
guys are just not going to do it that's
just going to be you're not going to be
able to get everybody to get the vaccine
but okay
let's just say most people get the
vaccine fine
what percentage of people are going to
move back to california
that's the question the moment somebody
moves out what percentage is going back
and said okay things are
clear that's the settle i'm moving back
to new york
i'm moving back to california what
percentage will go back so
the most important question on things
like this is how much of this is
permanent
yeah how much it is temporary
damage control what do you think i mean
look this is all
just sort of speculation but i think if
you're moving you're making a decision
to move your family if you especially if
you have kids if you have a family and
kids and you move you're gone
if you're a single guy you know how many
single people i know that have moved out
of new york into miami
literally every single friend i know
where are you from where you from from
where you live where you living
i was from new york i'm just down here
for a year it's a lot easier to you know
if you have flexibility if you're single
keep it moving obviously you know i've
been yeah
over the last 10 years if you've got
family you've got kids and you've got to
roll them in school and you're maybe
buying a house like you're gone
that's it a lot of people from
california moved to
nevada or they moved to arizona they
moved to tennessee some people obviously
to florida
i would say the the vast majority let's
say eighty percent are gone maybe twenty
percent
eighty percent are gone yeah if you're
families with kids
you're agreeing with this no no i agree
with you i actually agree with you i
think that
we got a first ding ding ding can i get
up i know i think that uh what ends up
happening is that like for example i
travel a lot
so i get to see a lot when you don't
leave california you don't realize
how with the laws and all this how bad
it is until you go to another state
you're like you can do that you're like
yeah it's
yeah we can how much you pay in taxes oh
wow
you start opening your eyes to a
different world so i think that once you
open your eyes to a different world
you realize that schooling is better you
realize that your second amendment is
not being infringed on
you realize that you know the government
is just kind of leaving you alone do
your thing build your business and we're
going to leave you alone
you're going to you know you go to red
states and it impresses you you're like
i can live like this in america you
don't really know in america california
you don't realize how much of a
chokehold you have until you leave
california
you don't realize that you can't do this
you can't do that you can't do this you
can't do that we can do this we can't do
this can't do that
until you go to another state where you
they're like we don't really care what
you're doing just don't kill anybody
we're good
just don't come in well i think
obviously the pandemic exacerbated
all of this because now it's acceptable
to wfa wfh work from home work from
anywhere it's completely acceptable
so if i asked you a year ago two years
ago ricky what are the chances that
you're moving to mississippi you'd be
like
bro no zero now if you can work from
anywhere
and you can own guns and and work from
anywhere and
be left alone and low taxes you might
consider living in a state that at a
million years you would have not
considered
not to call out our mississippi friends
whatever you know what's hurting some of
these states
here's what's hurting some of these
states so for example say
twitter says moving forward nobody ever
has to come into the office
right right i'll say i want to work for
twitter okay great
work for twitter but i want to work for
twitter living in texas living in nevada
living in nashville living in tennessee
living in calif living in uh
florida but i want to work for twitter
twitter says no problem you're hired
you're a coder
so i live in florida but i work for
twitter but i don't pay the taxes
of the state it doesn't matter who's
paying me i'm paying the state tax of
where i live which is what
florida so a lot of these companies in
silicon valley in new york
who went out there and started saying
what oh we're hiring people
virtually you don't have to be here they
actually hurt the state
they're actually hurt of course because
you pay taxes based on where you live
you don't pay taxes
based on where the company lives in some
cases they've also said i know
at least early on they said oh you'll
have a you won't have a silicon valley
rate if you if you don't live there
so they're paying proportionately
depending on where you live sure
they are yeah in that sense it's saving
them money to get
yeah but watch this but what does that
do think about what that does
again who does that hurt whether they go
lower or whether they go out of state
you know who else that even hurts even
more
people living in america because i can
now hire people if i'm going 100
zoom why the hell am i paying u.s rates
why wouldn't i twitter go higher
engineers have at india
out of philippines out of armenia these
places are producing some of the best
engineers
why am i even paying full price here i'm
not going to be in full price
so a big part of new york in california
what they did
they indirectly changed the business
model on how even
silicon valley and these financial
companies are working
this is not as you know small of a thing
as people think the consequences of
certain things you do
sometimes the side effects takes a
decade right to experience it right
i think this is gonna be a side effect
that's gonna take five to ten years for
us to really see what happened
you're gonna sit there and say what the
hell for example you go to glendale
where armenians at they live in glendale
where are syrians that they're in
turlock
where are uh you know venezuelans at you
know maybe orlando
miami a lot of them were orlando miami
where a lot of cubans that okay
you'll say miami where puerto rican
where dominicans at where i
was at where italians at new york why
because
once one community moves to a place they
typically tend to stay there
unless if you treat them what you know
you treat them bad and then they leave
right so
they have to know this could be a shift
taking place right now
and some of it is not done by
politicians believe it or not
some of it is done by these corporations
by these corporations who are leaning
far to being hey you know you can work
from home do whatever you want to do
they're hurting the state just as much
as the policies in the state are hurting
the state
right but do these corporations actually
care about the state they care about
their company
but here's the thing there used to be
time where you would be like hey you
know you know i want to have my
headquarters in new york
why because new york has the best what
talent
pool right you know i don't want to live
over here why because
now guess what the teleport is
everywhere the talent coolers everywhere
right so you can no longer say
i'm in new york because the talent pool
is in new york nope that's not the case
anymore
isn't that like the best thing for
capitalism though there's no
it's a fantastic thing for capitalism
it's a
beautiful thing for seven states but it
hurts
states like new york california and
illinois well new york can either adjust
or fall by the wayside they're not going
to judge they just impose another four
point three billion dollars
to make obviously and by the way they
just impose another 4.3 billion dollars
of taxes by cuomo
and they have to impose it there's
nothing they can do about it
the state's going to go bankrupt if they
don't get that 4.3 billion dollars
so cuomo's people are sitting there
saying if you don't raise this 4.3
billion dollars guess what
how the hell are we going to get we need
this money here so
he's in a pickle himself he's not
allowed i'm surprised i haven't recalled
yet
cuomo him yeah you know a lot of a lot
of uh efforts being made a lot of people
in california just waiting
uh to see what's gonna happen with
newsome before they leave like i know we
i know a lot of people have their finger
on the trigger they're just like okay if
we don't recall him we're out
because he has two more years on his
term uh but i know a lot of people
they're like
you know they're just waiting they're
just waiting to see what's gonna happen
with this recall
and if he gets recalled they're out
listen who doesn't get requested i hope
somebody from a little bit more
libertarian independent gets elected so
they can change the policies i hope
everybody's sick of it i hope everybody
is sitting there saying listen man we're
trying
to figure out what the recall was uh
democrats were democrats
yeah right think about your future
governor potential governor uh no that's
not even that's not that's a gentleman
that's
no none of them well if you had to vote
no
i don't know i don't even want that
that's bad that's bad that's bad
he's a republican no she's running as a
republican
caitlyn okay that's that that that's the
irony behind it
right you think that the community is
going to vote for him
if that was for her for her for her get
it straight
for her if if they were to because
versus newsome well because remember
republicans bad republicans anti-gay
remember supposedly according to
everybody
not according to her well according to
everybody that's the way it is
uh uh forgetting that obama was open
against gay marriage and trump
came into the office uh supporting gay
marriage so
you know it's kind of funny how the news
on that news knows how to
you know spin things but that's that's
kind of a good story caitlyn jenner's
story i'd rather go to the kamala harris
okay
i'd much rather go to the community
caitlyn jenner is considering running
for governor yeah i mean listen
as a republican the the the question
then you have to ask if we have pete
buduch which which is uh openly
gay mayor and look at that guy look
super smart guys look at the kind of
responsibilities he's been given
is america ready for a caitlyn i don't
know maybe california is yeah but i want
to show this guy can you pull up the
videos of what was shown
uh i'm almost certain uh ricky seen uh
this one
if you can make this bigger okay so this
was just shared last week
border patrol video showing children
being dropped
from border wall now watch it's a little
disturbing for parents
if you're watching this just just take a
look at this go ahead kai took them all
the way up to the wall
to the gear look at that how old is that
kid by the way right
three and five oh they said it three and
five three and five look at that look at
that look at the one
boom how far is that drop six feet i
know oh no
no 14 feet holy moly
it's like they're dropping uh dylan in
one center oh
my god from a 14 foot wall look at the
kid is still laying on the ground yeah
i think they dropped the little one next
i think that's the five year old and
then i think that's three-year-old if
i'm a mistake
oh buddy or something like that or the
other way around
yeah and they throw whatever package
they gave and
by the way pat let me let me here's
here's the reality behind things and
then they ran
here's the right behind things this
happens every day they just happen to
catch it
this happens every day you know i live
four hours after no
of course not especially right now i
live four hours from the border
i lived in mexico i want to school in
mexico uh you know
we're very familiar with what happens in
mexico one thing is to
and by the way not by and i mean this
with all due respect not by whitewashed
mexicans that watch the news and think
they know right
we have family there we have family in
tijuana we have family at the border
mexicali yep
we know what's going we go visit there
we go our families the mexican families
like for ours
our grandparents doctors are there like
we're always there we
know what's going the mexican community
knows what's going on with the mexican
community
right so it to me it's interesting and
i'm not not not because it is your
rights
it is your right to have your opinion i
think it's very interesting when
non-mexican people want to have an
opinion on what's going on with the
border
when they have no family there no direct
connection no phone call has what's
going on
that you you know it's like me having an
opinion on the country that i've never
lived in
and then you know like when i want to
know about a certain country i asked the
person like i talked to you
tell me about you know what's going on
in iran what happened you know i'll talk
to you about it
you know i don't know right and i could
try to read articles like all i want
that are edited by somebody else that
has also no freaking idea on what's
going on
and think that they know what's going on
so you know the reality is this happens
all the time
and the mexican community we knew this
was going to happen
we knew it and on top of that it's music
to the to the cartels
it's music to their ears they said open
borders let's go
i it's it's it's it's it was a stupidest
thing ever
you know everybody wants to seem like
they're you know you know everybody
wants to seem like they're woke
and thinking that was a good idea it was
a horrible idea
tell us why 33 percent of women okay so
the
the most the more south you live over
the border yeah
uh the women are being raped and
murdered so 33 of mexican women
are being raped 35 percent are being
murdered after they're raped
okay so when they're coming up by
coyotes 33
of the women are being raped by coyotes
or
thank you for correcting me okay thank
you for correcting me the women that are
coming up to the border they're being
raped by the coyotes or
by fellow uh uh migrants okay
and then that number gets worse the more
down south you go for example if you get
to the states of chappas
cancun people that are migrating the
more south they come up
salvadorians are notorious by the way
shout out to doors i love them to my to
my
compadre during my close friends the
salvadorians notoriously
immigrant salvadorians hate mexicans
because when they're crossing they go to
guatemala and they get treated
normal they get into mexico they have a
rate
give or take of 80 percent of their
women being raped because now they're in
mexico illegally
so they have two options from the
federals uh federal the federal police
state police and the military can you
show the map so everybody
yeah so they can understand the map of
south in south america
south america so what ends up it's
actually central america central central
america so so what ends up happening is
the
the the the these agencies are giving
them one of two options
either a you have sex with me or
i arrest you and i deport you so they've
already done the traveling you see
there you have guatemala right you have
beliefs in salvador
so if they have to go through they have
to go to especially salvadorians
so they go to guatemala they're cool
right because they're neighbors
but once they're coming from where
they're coming from
are you trying to bring your kids or
your family to us you have to go to
guatemala so so
and you also got to go through mexico
right so what ends up happening
you go to el salvador right you go to
guatemala they have to go through mexico
but remember
the salvador and guatemalans are
entering mexico
illegally so once they come across
against a
across a law enforcement agency in
mexico is corrupt
so you have one of two options either a
this is going to happen or b we're gonna
russian departure
so that's why illegal immigration
hurts hispanics it hurts them
because our women are being raped and
and murder a lot of them are being
murdered
i have a girl on my team she's not she's
no longer with
us anymore she she's doing a different
career but she sat in front of me and
she's like i have trust issues with my
boyfriend i'm like why
why would happen she was breaking down
she from el salvador
she was 15 or 16 years old raped by five
different men in mexico
so it's like it's it's people like they
watch the news and
yeah it's we should open the border to
everybody you don't know the damage
you're doing to these people
and on top of that people seem to think
it's not just your uncle juan that wants
to come more lawns
it's the human traffickers the organ
traffickers the child traffickers the
sex traffickers
there's more people in trafficking than
there's people that want to come work
does that make sense so people only
think one category my uncle juan that
wants to come mow lawns
no my boy behind him is six other
traffickers of different
organizations it's not just your uncle
juan that wants to come olans
does that make sense but the media will
never say that because they need the
votes
and mexicans typically hispanics are
very emotional
when you touch right and then what's the
excuse for me my parents came here
illegally
your parents came here illegally also
does that make it right
should i not care about these people now
that i understand how it works
should i just keep my mouth shut or
should i be an advocate for the truth
the truth is our women are being raped
and they're being killed and these kids
are being trafficked
they're grabbing kids and they're taking
the organs out of them and sell them in
the united states for people that are
dying old people that are dying that are
rich they can afford these organs
so it's like you just saw it happen by
the way that's one image
if the other video with the kid that got
the uh yes he they abandoned him yeah
that happens all the time none of this
is new but we know this have you seen
this
yes i have with the like 10 year old kid
who was the guy that found the kid can
you fast forward a little bit
the border control
might looks like it looks like a truck
it's a ford yeah more than like he's
going to be uh
look at this
[Music]
foreign
this happens all the time this happens
and we know it
the mexican people know it the ones that
actually sit there and understand what's
going on
that's why so many map so many first
generation now first generation
hispanics are turning conservative
and they're because we're not sitting
there in front of univision listening to
jorge ramos talk about how evil the
border is
we know what's going on the guy's just
turning a blind eye the idiot knows
what's going on
but of course you got to get the ratings
up right and you got to get the ratings
up by talking about what gets people
emotionally he cares about his career he
doesn't care about the mexican people
yeah it means a sellout let me ask you
ricky forget about just for a second the
u.s border because as i'm looking at the
map and anyone can see this right now if
you're coming from honduras or
el salvador that ain't a [ __ ] that in a
short walk
no brother to go through all of
guatemala
mexico to go through mexico city to even
make it to the border of texas or
california arizona
is a ridiculous trek so walk me through
the process of someone who's leaving el
salvador
because this is not a u.s issue at this
point this is a mexican mexican issue
this is a mexican here's a hypocrisy
ready here's a hypocrisy
the mexican president when the first
caravan came up from
honduras had the entire military at the
border to stop them
it's funny they talk about trump is bad
and racist because he wants to build a
wall yet the mexican government sent all
the military done to south mexico why
doesn't mexico build a wall
they have a wall in the south yeah can
you pull up the vehicle can you pull up
the video
where the mexican military was holding
back the caravan mexican military holds
back the caravan at the southern border
watch
watch watch the hypocrisy okay so uh
uh at southern border um let me see if
there's a
is there is there uh images let me see
okay
there it is the the go down all of them
all of them
but there's a border there they had
crossed that's the mexican military well
guatemala blocks houses for us
the hypocrisy the freaking hypocrisy
here we are met at the american
government but yet here's here's the
watch out with the channel watch out
with the channel so so here's uh
yeah right there like for example you
any of those pictures right there right
what a monoblocks what am i
security force what border is that
happening the guatemalan border because
remember they got into guatemala and
mexico
and then and then they're digging this
isn't even a us issue with this no
it's everything so at the end of the day
everything there's a mexican more than
anything
every country sovereignty is being
violated not just the american one but
of course jorge ramos is not going to
tell you this
don lemon aoc won't tell you this
they're not going to tell you this we
can give you some solutions that you
think because obviously it's a problem
whether you're republican whether you're
a democrat whatever you are it's a
freaking problem
and whether it's obama whether it's
trump whether it's biden no one's
figured out the solution
give us the solution look in your
opinion here's here's here's here's the
reality behind things
we the reality is this every country
needs to take care of their people
okay so maybe maybe to a certain extent
they got to get better at electing the
president and start being so emotional
the reason that this prayer like for
example the president of mexico amlo
he's a socialist he's a bernie sanders
of mexico how do you get voted emotional
mexico's rich so is venezuela by the way
with oil well they used to be but well
they
well but they with the oil right so what
ends up happening
you got to stop voting emotionally you
know a lot of people like to blame
america for the
the problems in in other countries we
didn't tell them to vote the way they
did
right like maduro travis we didn't
create travis and maduro they created
themselves and then people voted for
them because they spoke nice
everybody likes to blame america for
other countries problems i have this
conversation with liberals all the time
oh venezuela's going to it's because
america no bro it's because of them
yeah i agree okay it's not our fault no
okay stop it
right i don't know who would think that
it's america's fault
many people are voting many people i
don't know many americans who
brother know what the hell is going on
talking about what are you talking about
you know a lot of americans who are very
uh vocal on honduras
there are a lot of americans that say
that's the work of america
america did that to venezuela america
did this took that stance
yeah and that's why he says that's why
we have to take him right
so ramas he's a dog is on university
he's a don lemon of he's a dominator
what's his um approval ratings among
bro they love him oh he is uh he's like
he's
i'll put it to you this way i said it
the other day i'm gonna tell you guys
right now pastors
no longer have uh uh priests and pastors
no longer have pa
power over the hispanic people you don't
know who he is you know
i know who he is so so so now
pastors and priests no longer have power
over the american j with the jedi
jorge ramos right this is this is a
sellout this is a sellout so
anyway here's a lot but um
latin americans love him the old school
ones
the first generation like myself no
longer do so his approval rating amongst
our generation is going down
but a lot of people like him give us
some solutions back to the solution
so so the i don't know about i don't
know there is a solution but here's the
reality behind things
people here's here's here's here's look
bro i lived in mexico lakes i lived in
mexico
on school in mexico uh you know just
small periods when i was there with my
dad
okay people in mexico
they're gonna show you images of like
bad we can show you images of
people living in tension l.a and make it
seem like that's the whole
the united states okay there's people in
mexico don't starve to death
people in el salvador don't starve to
death people in guatemala don't starve
to death that's just the truth
and some of the viewers may not agree
because they watch too much news okay
but they don't start i have
family there i have ants that are
missionaries that live in those
countries people don't start
they're not afraid hold on hold on hold
on it's not africa
they're not starving to death because
they still have social programs because
they have money because oil
united states gives them money so
they're not starving they're you don't
see what kids
their ribs coming out you just don't so
the reality is the solution is
stay in your country until you fix your
papers and then come
that's the because it's too dangerous of
a road to take you're gonna be the
chances of you being trafficked
uh uh you're being killed or raped are
too high
but of course they're never gonna show
those numbers on the news but brother
let me ask you
they're not starving to death i'm trying
to work towards the solution not that
we're gonna figure out a solution here
why are all these people leaving their
countries there's there's got to be
obviously
a lot of corruption a lot of gangs a lot
of murders
that that even want to leave i don't
know many people that want to leave
their country unless there's something
going bad
pat's family would have never left iran
if iran would still run before
bro it was war-torn in everything these
countries are not war-torn
okay but why are they still leaving
because if there's an opportunity
they wouldn't leave if they lived in in
in somewhere in uh
in a uh a lot of them in the middle east
they wouldn't take the routes
people are staying there but these
people are leaving i get it
for a reason because it's only two
countries because there's only two
countries up and if you're saying coming
we're gonna take you of course you're
gonna leave
but it's nothing new bro like you said
this has been going on for years and
years and years
because if you offer it my family my
family in mexico none of them would ever
starve to death
never why in mexico i'm asking about
honduras
look the news might try to make it
otherwise let me ask you a question are
you asking
what's the solution from the standpoint
of the country of mexico or what's the
solution from the standpoint of america
all the above no it's a different
question if you're in america
okay there's only one solution in my
opinion what's that you need to invest
in these countries so people won't leave
their countries
brother to corrupt the governments are
corrupt okay so what do we do
like we'll see who keeps voting
emotional immigration but that's nothing
to do with america bro that's something
that people in honduras
so you know what the cold-hearted answer
is stop voting for those idiots
dude i mean that no no that's what you
know i'm sorry that's the truth bro
but who's thought it's like it's not
like i'm involved in honduras politics
who's voting for them
no but but but we have to we have to
think about we okay so go back look at
it from the perspective of
us stuff that we have control over we
don't have control over a
corrupt corrupt government president how
they make their money
you are you can invest as much money as
you want into a country like that
you can put 20 billion dollars into iran
iran's not changing their philosophy
there's a revolution so you can say oh
let's invest 100 billion dollars into
iran iran still hates america not
iranians
the iranian politicians at the top yeah
they still hate america
they don't sit there wake up and say
let's figure out a way to get better
with the west
last time that happened was when the
showers are on right okay
question becomes america not not mexico
right now
this is a topic of america what can
america do
to prevent a lot of these things
happening when you say
hey we got to take care of the people
that are coming across the border and
give them a place to stay at
you're saying you're saying come on down
come on down so words have consequences
especially when you're a president
here's kamala harris an article came out
from new york post
where is kamala two weeks since being
named border cesar
harris borders are harry still hasn't
visited
the border president biden named harris
on march 24 to head up the
diplomatic effort to reach out to the
leaders of mexico and central american
countries
about the flood of immigrants a migrant
saying she
speaks for me but so far she has only
phoned guatemalan president alejandro
yamate and mexico's andres manuel lopez
uh
abrador to discuss root causes of the
crisis instead in her first two weeks as
czar she has traveled to connecticut
chicago and home to california over the
easter weekend and has
presided over swearing in ceremonies
touted the administration's chronovirus
stimulus package and covet
response visited the vaccination sites
launched with the press
launched with the president attended a
cabinet meeting and held listening
sessions
with faith leaders and small business
owners her public schedule showed
asked at the white house briefing
wednesday about when harris might travel
to the border press
secretary jen sackey said
there is no trips on the schedule i
don't have any trips to outline or
preview
what our focus is on is solutions and
ensuring we have more beds we're making
the processing more efficient and
effective and that
we are addressing this in a human way
that keeps these kids as safe as
possibly we can
she said of the surging numbers of
accompanied minors
showing up to the crossing okay at the
crossing so here's one thing look
um say what you want to say about bill
clinton he showed up
say what you want to say about bush he
showed up crisis happened he's there the
next day
say what you want to say about trump he
showed up he showed up he's like hey
what's going on over here
what the hell is going on with even
showing up you know if this is the kind
of a crisis that we're having right now
why don't you go see for yourself why
don't you go show some support why don't
you go support some of the guys that
don't have the easiest job it's not the
easiest job to be the guy
that's finding the kid that's not an
easy job right now their job at the
border is not an easy job so
u.s okay let's let's see the reason why
people are coming to america is what
because america is still
the greatest country in the world so
people want to come where to america
okay you don't see people coming from
canada down here as much as we got
people from mexico el salvador coming up
here people don't go across on the
border from canada the way they are
crossing the border
here that says a lot about canada good
for canada for being a neighboring
country mexico a different story can you
really
influence politically making these calls
i don't know i don't know how much you
can do that the way trump did it was the
following
if you don't fix it there is tariffs
if you don't fix it there's more tariffs
if you don't fix it
there's more taxes that got the
attention of people very quickly
okay we're like okay listen let's get
this together so why don't you say hey
mexico
if you don't fix the border issue that
you are causing for us
here's a tariff it's very simple now i'm
just telling you what we're going to do
to you
this is the tax you got to pay us you
still don't want to fix it another
tariff
you still don't want to fix it another
tariff do you remember when trump said
mexico is going to pay for the wall you
know what was the most disappointing
thing that americans were upset about it
what are you upset about it why are you
upset if he makes
mexico pay for the wall what's the big
deal why are you so upset that you're
defending them have
they should pay for the wall we're not
going over their border they should pay
for the wall right
this isn't something where you're look
so let's just say uh you're president
biden or kamal hares okay
would you say this is a pretty urgent
issue that's taking place today is this
a pretty urgent issue
yes is it okay is it how urgent is it
right now what's going on to texas
arizona and california because they're
on the border
how urgent this is a pretty big damn
issue it's a pretty big issue that's the
biggest issue what is the biggest issue
number one by far and away is coveted
but kovitz has already been solved
because we have no what i mean by that
is the fact that we have
the uh what he called we have the
vaccine we have some progress that we're
making so it's not like
we're in the process of making that
better right
what even brings more vacs more coveted
if you've got hundreds of people
thousands of people that are around each
other in different facilities yeah if
covet is your number one why don't you
pay attention to the borders a lot of
these people coming over
a big of course they do that they could
create a bigger spread
i don't know man i i think uh for me i
like
the fact when you say you know it's been
very quiet you know ever since biden got
elected you don't hear a lot of
different problems
yeah i kind of want you to go there asap
and sit down and see what's going on
you're the president man we're paying
you to go do your job and this is an
issue that we're facing right now all
you got to do is get on that air force
one
plane of yours with a few hundred secret
service guys go out there and see what's
going on
make some tough decisions let's move
forward rather than sitting there saying
well
you know i don't know what we're going
to do here if we put too many tariffs
and they're going to say we're doing
what trump did and i want to be compared
to this
forget about it i don't think they're
playing offense to figure out a solution
well you know he's reconsidering to
build the wall to continue the wall
he has no choice because people are not
saying that it worked right
people are now saying maybe we do need
it so that whole concept about a wall
calling them racist yeah
now people are starting to realize maybe
we do kind of need a wall
the part ricky my challenge is the
following
which there's a part i agree with you
here is which i don't know you may agree
with what i'm going to say but i think
what you're going to say
why are people leaving mexico what can
mexico do what can this do
central american country listen you're
america you know if you're america
impose yup some tariffs go ahead hey
mexico you don't figure this out i'm not
lifting the tariffs
and these tariffs are going to stay for
six months and by
90 days from now if i don't have a
resolution and a report showing me with
what exactly you're doing
guess what we're raising the tariffs
again and within six months
if you haven't done xyz tariffs are
going up again i'm going to put a tier
of tariffs with timelines on them
i'm going to say 90 days by 90 days you
need this between now and then 10
90 days to 180 days if you don't meet
that it goes to 20
180 days to 270 days if you don't meet
that 30 percent
270 days for 365 60 days if you don't
meet that 40 percent guess what
motivates that i want to get this done
because that creates a level of urgency
tied with deadlines let's get to work we
want to help you
we want to be able to accommodate you
but at the same time this is an issue
because you're
you're throwing your problems at us and
we don't want to do that we don't want
to see videos like this this is hard
work you know what's one of the
common things i uh threads i read here
with people commenting below
parents saying i can't even watch that
video comment if you look at it if
somebody's
saying i can't even watch that video
some of the comments we got juan garcia
gave five dollars he said as a hispanic
parent
so heartbreaking to see those images
jorge ramos is a hispanic puppet for the
left
shout out to ricky for keeping it real
right you're getting people that are
watching this saying this is
this is tough to watch this is not easy
to watch and it's happening and what are
you doing
you're going to different events yeah i
don't know about that that doesn't show
leaders you know what you know what the
most disappointing part about it is
fyi fyi yes pat this doesn't help you
know the whole thing that they're saying
kamala's going to be president
this doesn't help her re-election stuff
go ahead you know what the crazy part
about it is though
it's it's what i'm really disappointed
in a lot of my friends are watching this
and are going to watch this
is how many of you guys and i'm going to
say this to you to my i'm talking to my
friends
that supported biden how many of you
guys voted for him
because trump was a racist and uh
because that's what they used to to
brainwash you and then on top of that
how quiet you are about what's going on
get its inner face
it was never this bad our people our
people that carry our
forget about the skincare because i
don't i don't believe in division they
carry our culture
our country right now are literally
going through this and how many people
are quiet about it
i mean it was a daily post trump is
racist trump is racist
wall is racist trump is racist but now
everything's good
because the racist guy is out of the
office according to them
it's just insane to me like it's so
disappointing as a mexican
hardcore i have a centenario on my on my
chest which is a 100th anniversary of
mexico it's a coin they make every
hundred years
i'm i lived in mexico my dad lives in
mexico i have property in mexico i
go there often uh my family is that i
went to school there i just went and
buried my uncle my grandmother and my
uncle
i'm a part of my i'm a mexican citizen i
have a dual citizenship
i'm not a whitewashed mexican that lives
over here watches the news and reads a
couple articles i think they're woke
i i i'm very objective i remember when i
was living there i was 18 years old and
i lived there
i was there for a year one of the times
uh we would actually party right with my
friends
that were and by the way with families
that are well off that they were going
to cross i remember
vividly i was there we were at a barn
okay i still remember it's called desvan
right and it's no longer there there's
one and i'm from the trucklong which is
a very
it's a very dangerous state to be in
right so it's torn in the cartel war
and there were three of them we're going
to go illegally and we're like getting
on
we're getting drunk the night before
because we're partying for them and
they go up they all three got caught
they came back and we threw a party
because they were back
these are not starving people so when
you're you're sitting there
and you're a mexican that lived here
your entire life and you
don't you don't even know where your
parents are from and you want to have an
opinion on this
when you don't know what's going on then
there's the stupidest thing ever because
you you let the news rile you up
i was there i saw them leave the town
with well-off families
they just want to go just do something
better go experience another country
it's
it's almost like a vacation to someone i
don't want to say that about all of them
it's unfair for me to
categorize everybody like that but i
know my fair share of people that had no
need to come down here
and they're coming down here and
everybody over here wants to feel bad
because the news is making you feel
better when they're pretty good where
they're at
so you know let's just talk numbers
right now i'm not against immigration by
the way i want you to know
obviously we're immigrants you're
against you're pro-legal immigrants
i'm pro-you're not getting raped and
trafficked okay so be very
clear just quick numbers for you while
we um
before we move on um because you brought
up you know this is not a good look for
kamala if she's going to be the
um immigration czar um
border czar so let's just talk numbers
let's talk approval ratings biden's
approval ratings
for his handling of covid and the
vaccine 75 percent
that's very insane very high meaning
that he did nothing for it
previous administration created the
vaccine that's the fact sure so own it
so
tell people to get vaccinated then if
you're trump no he didn't i'm just
saying
okay no i'm debatable i'm independent
when he when biden came into office
because obviously they were talking
about his plan
when he was campaigning he was saying
this down the other oh we're gonna we're
gonna
put together an action plan and then as
soon as he got elected he said
basically it's just got to run its
course okay there you go
let's let's just talk numbers for a
second his approval rating he just made
a very good point just so you know that
when they ask them i have a plan when i
get elected i'll tell you about it when
he got elected said we just have to let
her run its course there was no plan
okay yeah the only but go ahead he's got
77 approval ratings
75 on cobit border border patrol uh
situation at the border in the 40s so if
you're looking at numbers and if kamal
is the person that's going to be the
border czar
you can walk and chew gum at the same
time you can handle kovid
and and do well and get vaccinated and
do everything right
but also get kamala's ass down to the
border and make this
situation go away and fix this problem
so i i don't know if the
wall is the solution i think it's more
policies than wall
because there's something called tell me
if you're familiar with this title 42
yes
so tell me i don't know i i know that i
i'm familiar with the
title 42 i don't know the ins and outs
of it but this is basically a policy
situation
that trump implemented biden came in
with an executive action
and removed it so listen part of
part of being voting for biden or being
a republican is that you can have tough
love
you can love your kids and say bro you
got to do better here your report card
sucks
so my advice to joe and kamala whatever
is
keep doing what you're doing on covid
things are getting better but get your
act together when it comes to the border
because this is a human
a humanitarian disaster but hold on
it's deeper than that the man hasn't
done anything in 42 years 47 years
why would you have an expectation of a
vote for a person that's never done
anything
literally you've got a video hold on you
can't say he's never done anything are
you serious
okay you're right massive incarcerated
blacks by the night in the night today i
like right you're doing it you're right
using the problem again gotta get it no
oh it's probably together
or or they're on the books who won the
election
that's that's beside the point we're not
gonna go there no we're not no we're not
i hope you brought cash
no we're not going to do it no we're not
going to go there did you bring it guys
ricky
we're going to don't i believe in you
bro we're not going to go there we're
not going to go there
okay no we're not because we're not so
the point is this
here's a reality behind things trump in
his forties
broad manhattan out of ruins that's the
truth when he was in the studies and
forties
actually brought him in and said what
can we do to fix manhattan he
brought manhattan to where it's at right
what two certainly said hebrew trump
brought manhattan are you serious
they signed meetings they had city
council meetings they had city councils
where he was re-helping them rebuild
they said
do this do this do this do this do this
let me build here let me let me build
here
he's the one that brought life to it
right and that
you or you'd or am i wrong if i'm wrong
tell me i'm wrong you have to agree with
me i don't think trump was the sole
reason manhattan is what it is okay you
don't think he was the biggest influence
for it
he was the biggest voice at the time i
think he did his fair share but i think
there's a lot of freaking people that
of course i'm not saying i'd say rudy
giuliani
but everything needs a pioneer right he
was a pioneer for it sure okay
right did our forefathers get the
country to work right now no
the living the forefathers no they
fought for the to get rid of
british and then they established the
constitution and we're here now but we
had to continue
that legacy okay okay that's what i'm
getting at okay so what i'm getting at
is the man has already had previous
success
what has biden done he hasn't done
anything but enforce uh a few laws that
go against mastercard
and then what a kamala hair is actually
known for lock up a brother that was her
nickname
so so why would you have any
expectations for people who have done
nothing for the communities to begin
with
and then expect them to go into office
and want to have expectations for them
it's like having a dog biting you and
then saying don't bite me
it bites you when it's adopted and then
and then when you're like don't bite me
when i own this is the exact same thing
that we talk about
what's your point my point is why do you
have any expectations you should have
known this happened so it should have
zero expectations for the president of
the united states
why would you if you already knew the
track record no no that's why
you're a smart guy no okay okay okay let
me let me let me clarify
your expectations hold on let me clarify
it for you then let me clarify for you
then
okay democrats voted for him that are
not happy and what he's doing should not
be surprised
you already know he has nothing going on
there's different issues brother no
because
there's there's no difference there's
covet there's immigration yeah there's
taxes
there's policies he don't care
tell me one category he's doing good in
he's doing it in texas covent
he's doing good in kovitz 75 percent
approval rating it doesn't matter what
ignorant people think the question
becomes who who started it
he said we got to let it take its course
trump should get out there and tell
people he already did i started this
white supremacy i said yes he did 26
times remember when i said that
okay publicly he's already publicly
saying to do it
so what are you talking about he hasn't
talked about it more often
he's not the president anymore they took
him off of every single social media let
me ask you do you listen to what trump
has to say
not everything you respect what he has
to say i respect what do you feel in
certain categories
listen ricky yes i want you to go get
vaccinated no sir i'm an independent
i'm an independent thinker i don't i
don't solely follow
one man i like i could like a lot of
what he does without liking certain
things
okay that's what happens when you're an
independent thinker right
well played sir okay all right all good
uh
by the by the way he did tell people to
get a vaccine but he said
i came up to expedite the process of
vaccine
not biden taking credit for it yeah
trump is what made it happen within nine
months if it wasn't trump it would have
been yes
18 months because even founds you said
it's going to take 18 months whether
it's fouchy whether it's trump whether
it's biden
is this trump implemented a plan made it
happen fauci's telling people to wear
them
but they won the super bowl last year
okay because of who
because of more than just brady yeah
because tom brady showed up and then he
led the team
true yeah okay he but there's people out
there making tackles there's people out
there catching passes
there's people out there blocking it's
not just tom brady bro it's just not
just trump
it's not just binding it's not just
foundation it's rhetoric it's a team
effort you gotta be
kidding me no it's not a chief officer
you're so naive to say something it's
not a team effort
you're so naive to say it's all trump
trump it's not its own
trump made the vaccine he distributed
the vaccine he was there with the with
the beakers and
he's making the vaccine what are you
saying can you get this guy cookie
please just give me a goddamn cookie
something
bro okay okay so did the venice is a
team effort the venezuelan people ruined
venezuela
this is a team effort it wasn't my
little or travis i'm sure they had this
oh okay
wasn't hitler what do you saw what are
you saying what are you what are you
saying what are you saying
it's a it's a team effort is it team
effort then hillary clinton
hillary didn't pioneer it hitler didn't
pioneer that karl marx didn't pioneer
socialism no
no no no no no i'm not because let's say
there's a driver
did hitler make him or did he drive him
dude
who made him dumb no it's not dumb bro
it goes back to what you're trying to
say all right let's get this stupid
we're done here it ended well you guys
good giving
yourself a good thank you guys a little
update from the polls here uh
adam's approval rating has risen to four
percent here
on the uh twitter by the way let me if
you're enjoying the dialogue right now
listen this is what i like i like banter
i like debate that's how we learn if we
sit here and all of us agree on
everything
nobody learns this is how i learned this
is how my board meetings are this is how
my meetings are
and it's working very well specifically
today and we're still friends by the way
i love this guy he's getting me
yesterday he takes happy birthday like
we have a great relationship we could
this
this is the way america should oh it
should be a hundred percent we should
disagree
yes and so have lunch afterwards and be
good we still got an hour and nine
minutes to go guys
i do want to tell you i want to give a
shout out to a couple if you're enjoying
this
uh smash that thumbs up button if you're
here for the first time join us
subscribe to the channel
and click on the notification button so
when it goes out you're uh uh
you're uh getting your notification let
me give a quick shout out to a few
people that
uh the donation today for whatever
reason's
pretty high okay hi pat this is ramiro
gonzalez ten dollars i'm trying to
launch an app three to four relatively
big players in the market my biggest
competitor just raised two million
dollars
is there anything you'd recommend when
going up against a golight i made a
video about it
you ought to go watch it okay uh 499 was
by heavy
hall mercenary saying candace owens is
the furthest person
right is what he says a.g just gave ten
dollars to give ten dollars thank you
troy gilo just gave 25 bucks just to
give 25 bucks
nelson j five dollars thank you sanchi
gave uh uh 200
ars uh percue crack adam
hablano espanol okay i have no clue what
he just said
ass adam speaks speak spanish
mr clean bald guy is back i tweeted what
he said last week by the way fantastic
have adam google how much taxes were
paid in 1964.
click on the revenue act of 1964. it's
the first
link uh read the impact i'm curious i'm
gonna look at that myself
pbd thanks for the quote on twitter you
got it buddy chad williams
ten bucks when i went through la pre
covid had a buddy take me through skid
row it was literally like going through
the uh going to the third world
worst about it is mass help mental
health problems and business owners
stuck behind tents
interesting chad williams and by the way
chad williams is a guy that will go
left or right when it comes down to
commenting uh he still gave the five
bucks on that let me see what else we
got here chad williams another five
dollars what about rock running for
president we've talked about that before
in the past
uh yemi mourinho gave 50 amen preach u.s
media univision and telemundo are sale
sellouts to hispanic communities
spreading lies to the democratic party
that's based on your conversation
uh reuben ramirez ricky what were the
best advantages of growing up in the
streets
and what would you say to someone who's
looking to become a legitimate
businessman entrepreneur what were the
toughest obstacles maybe you want to
answer that right oh
what was the truth growing up in the
streets uh i grew up some of you guys
don't know
um i grew up in east baker school which
is the second biggest barrio in
in in california outside of east l.a um
actually the founder of the california's
mexican mafia maker so he grew up
six blocks from where i was grew up in
beale street um
and so there's a lot of heavy influence
there uh i think number one thing would
be to get away from those people
right which is associations get away
from people that have that mentality
uh and by the way let me make one thing
here because a lot of my friends are
watching a lot of my friends i grew up
in the hood with it i love very much
and there's and there and some of them
are still there some of them are out um
but it's
it's limiting my association with the
the people that have the mentality that
i used to have
right and then uh limiting my visits to
the neighborhood
i'll go now to go cut my hair to go buy
things but i don't go to visit anybody
there anymore um uh but that's that's
number one number two is
uh one you know you and i'm just gonna
give them a shout out because you've
interviewed me you're friends with them
is uh i read the book
by robert kiyosaki rich dad poor dad to
help me change my mentality
to understand what it is to be a
business owner and then find a proven
mentor you know in this case i was able
to
first of all my brother got into
business uh then uh
alejandro my brother alhamdulillah
into this business because i come from a
family of entrepreneurs uh that were in
financial services so uh then you know
from there i was coached by hector and
eric shout out to them
and then jose mourinho which is the
older brother older brother sister to uh
hector america and then pat so
uh it's finding proven mentors and then
staying within that association
i think to me my number one thing is
association
uh you're gonna be a direct reflection
of the five people that you're on the
most that your income is gonna be a
reflection of the five people that
you're around the most
and a lot of the reason that i'm
passionate about the things that i'm
passionate about now is because pat kind
of brought light to it
so what ends up happening is that you're
kind of in the dark in a lot of things a
lot of subjects
you're in the dark and so somebody says
hey have you looked at this all they got
to do is point a finger
for you to look at and then you're like
wow i did not know that
right so that's kind of that's kind of
the the
the road that i would say to take is
again to break it down number one
get away from associations to have the
same lifestyle number two
start reading self developing number
three find a proven mentor you know
anybody's willing to mentor that you
admire that you know and they could be a
priest it could be a pastor you know for
us as dudley
and on a spiritual side find it find a
way out and just stick with that
community that would be my by the way
to tell you how much ricky has
influenced the latino community in his
surrounding area this is just the
beginning of what he's going to be doing
with this impact because
this messaging coming from from somebody
like this who grew up there
the level of credibility he has to say
here's where i was
here's who i was here's what i did
here's the proof
this is what i believe today we ought to
change or else uh
well i've told ricky this a million
times this is a lot of what the
republican party needs especially
no question about it like if you see a
guy like this yeah rather than the male
pale and stale crowd that you see when
they're lining up on
the trumpet pictures this is someone
that i think people can get behind
this is someone that even a democrat can
say you know what this [ __ ]
but you know what i think i think
there's a certain extent of the the suit
the suit let me let me let me uh
i'm gonna send something to kai real
quick pat if you don't mind go for it i
think that uh
sometimes a lot of times uh uh what is
it called the the suit
uh may uh uh just pull that for them so
i'm gonna send a
i'm gonna send something i want you to
just take your clothes no no i'm not
gonna do that right now
i'm actually going to send this uh i'm
going to send this like maybe while
you're doing that let me ask you a
follow-up yes sure while you're doing
that so
maybe i could pull this up real quick so
people know what i look like without a
shirt not completely just you know
so i'm going to the male model picture
so um respect to you thank you for
watching what you're doing bro real talk
um you talked about limiting your trips
to the body or literally your trips to
the hood
obviously you're associating yourself
with pbd and the del toros and the guy
tons respect to them if they're
listening sapala everyone oh 100 percent
yes
i love those guys yeah um you're talking
about eliminating how what kind of
backlash are you getting from your
people saying bro you sold out
no you're not with us bro you talked
about it i gotta i suspect you're seeing
stuff like that yeah you know what if
you know what the crazy part is i
i don't because i'm not around them i
don't hear it
so when you go around them oh you think
you're better than me now no no actually
oh you think you're there no actually
you know surprisingly enough bro
surprisingly enough
when i like i go get a my company owns a
barber shop so i go cut my hair in the
in my neighborhood two three times a
week and when i'm getting haircuts
put it back up yeah so yeah so yeah of
course so that's that's what i look like
without a shirt so i'm completely and
that's the way my damn near
uh you know 75 percent of my body looks
i'm i'm completely tattooed
and i have my murals you know i have my
my hat the roosters where i'm from it's
big on the rooster in the rooster world
so
uh my family were raised yeah so so i
this is this is how i look without my
shirt i want to take my shirt in my back
i have my back completely tattooed as
well
i grew up in the neighborhood so anyway
point is that uh
to answer your question though no i
don't get it i don't get a lot of it a
lot i'm gonna
train i i i can see that yeah but here's
why though because
his arguments make sense there is
credence behind it
when there's credibility and weight
behind your word people have to listen
okay you have no matter how much a
person doesn't like a
doctor if a doctor's got the credibility
to say for the last you know like ron
paul will
get up and say i've done four thousand
uh uh i've delivered four thousand
babies right
if he tells you about delivering babies
guess what you have to say okay
i never delivered a baby you know four
thousand you got credibility yeah you
only have the history you got you got to
kind of listen by the way
if you're listening to this if you're
listening to this and you like what
ricky had to say today
uh it's his birthday today i'm gonna put
the comment below with the link to
exactly is this the instagram account go
give them a follow and send them a
message
and stay in contact with them uh i just
put the link right there you ought to
see it go real quickly
and follow and give them some love it's
also in the description okay perfect so
we got to both places sabatimani family
is watching
good to have you guys shut up
uh by the way jack e just gave five
bucks specifically to you
and said patrick are the rumors true
that adam is planning to run for
president of chaz
is that his seattle chess
that's good stuff that's hilarious i got
a few other people here adam follow up
adam follow up pbd's preaching and
recent learners of people from honduras
guatemala el salvador don't live in
corrupt governments
juan garcia five bucks mass legal and
illegal immigration is bad it hurts
wages and salaries against
many immigrants don't assimilate to
rules and culture of america as a
mexican i can honestly say mexico is a
failed culture
ten bucks sarafin then we got a few
other people that just gave five dollars
i wonder what he means by that
i don't understand mass legal or illegal
immigration is bad it hurts wages
similar to what you said okay and
salaries and many immigrants don't
assimilate
and assimilate to rules and culture of
america meaning they're coming here
they don't say oh i love them you know i
mean the other one said i feed another
one the one before that or after that
where it says that mexican cultures
failed i don't know what he meant by
that mexican as a
mexican i honestly can say that mexico
is a failed culture
country mexico is a field coach i don't
know what it is if you want to elaborate
on it
we'll come back to it yeah a little bit
more specific yeah sean ellis
five bucks trump has had this fix would
remain in mexico in the wall
and ending catch and release but biden
flipped all of those
and now we have a non-stop flow of 20
years uh uh
some guy five dollars illegal
immigration costs u.s taxpayers 116
billion dollars per year yep
and we got woods dog we got a few other
people here that said what they said but
uh
let me get back to okay mexico needs uh
to send its military into central
america and concrete the us better stay
out of it
since they don't care expand the
fatherland nc styles
five bucks all right that is what it is
wow that's uh that's what's the father
that's
totally that's best for yeah he's
talking about taking over the countries
all right so let's let's talk about
amazon let's talk about amazon let's
talk about what amazon did here page
four if you want to go
go to page four uh amazon
so a few things going on with amazon
i'll read both the stories and you tell
me your thoughts on it one
this is a business insider story amazon
is snapping up this used shopping malls
and turn them into fulfillment centers
malls that buckled
due to e-commerce or suffered during the
pandemic are being given new life by the
very
entity that uh precipitated that their
decline
amazon last year amazon was reportedly
in talks
with simon property group the country's
biggest mall owner to convert
many bankrupt jc penneys and sears
department of stores into fulfillment
centers about fifty percent of all base
department stores
could permanently close by the end of
2021 according to green street let me
read that one more time
about 50 of mall based department stores
could permanently
close by the end of 2021 that is half of
malls
close amazon's signature prime delivery
depends on its national network of more
than 100 fulfillment centers and roughly
1 million
workers to get the packages to customers
front door within a day or even an hour
what do you think about the strategy
that amazon's taking
i mean this isn't a new story we've
covered this but that malls are closing
and the amazon fulfillment centers are
taking over and
it's just it is what it is the reality
is these malls these retail shopping has
been declining for years and years and
years online shopping has risen and
risen
and it's a natural progression if who
else is going to go into these
what they call anchor stores these sears
these macy's these jc pennies
who the hell is going in there there's
been some ideas about
freaking theme parks going into these
type of things the reality is is one
door closes another door opens and
amazon is just going to fulfill
literally fulfill that open
location yeah i know i i think i agree
with i agree with adam when it comes
down to that i mean
you know here's here's what it comes
down to you know i'm kind of spit on
this i was having a conversation with
vanessa earlier before we started here
she worked at an amazon
uh warehouse and uh we'd like to hear
what she has yeah you know i actually be
you know but it's you know she was
saying how the
the the workers get treated or whatever
the case may be
uh i think it's a double-edged sword so
let me let me let me explain what i mean
by that
as far as amazon is concerned do i like
a lot of people don't like you know
bernie sanders made everybody hate
amazon
i love amazon um amazon uh saves you
a trip for possibly getting uh in a car
accident
right because it'll bring you to your
stuff your next day so now parents can
spend more time teaching their kids they
don't have to go to i have to run their
store you can just order it'll be there
the next day
i think amazon has really uh upgraded
the quality of life in many different
ways
in a capitalistic sense because again
you know if i'm doing homework with my
kid and i need
and i need you know toilet paper i can
literally just order it online while i'm
helping them it gives you more time at
home with your family it gives you more
time to work on your business i know i
use amazon every i order from amazon
out of 30 days probably about 25 of the
days right so
it helps you with your it just helps
your different in different in different
areas
now it is the richest company in the
world now and i'm kind of a little bit
uh
one of one of them i think apple's
marketing is is it i know amazon was
bigger than
was it market cup i think apple's at 2
trillion okay amazon's at 1.5 but it's
still
it's very influential yeah so so i like
it i like the idea of them going into
because
fulfillment centers because it's making
your life easier like you said it's
progression
you know um now there's been a lot of
complaints about how it treats its
workers that's kind of
you know i'm concerned about that so i
want you to go to that next door i'm
going to go into i want to hear from
vanessa
you so tell us about you worked at
amazon before yes i did i was a
work a fulfillment fulfillment worker uh
this warehouse in doral that's miami
basically and it's funny how you say
that
they want to make uh customers happy and
i'm i'm
all about that but i'm wondering how
they would treat their
employers in these new facilities that
they want to replace the most because
honestly
in my warehouse at least they didn't
treat me with respect at all
the managers yeah the managers like
respect us
can you tell us tell me more about that
what do you mean by that i mean
uh they wouldn't that they would
actually disrespect us
like for example very basic thing if i
need to go to the restroom i just go
but for them was like oh okay well you
instead of five minutes you took seven
minutes that's a that's a write-up
or for example yeah or for example if
your bag hurts because you've been
lifting boxes all day
yeah okay um instead of uh
taking you to a less heavy duty section
that we do have instead of boxes
just envelopes yeah they would write you
up for that too or suspend you for two
weeks it's just not i don't know how
the new idea is gonna become i hope it's
better to be honest but in my experience
there's no respect at all
and do you think that's something the
overall sentiment from workers was that
your experience does your friends have
similar experiences what's your take on
that the entire warehouse
i because i don't like to talk battle
about
any uh company
but then my entire warehouse felt the
same way that i do
i know that 100 at least from the
associate level that was my position
associate
when it becomes to managers of course
you're like the king and the queen
i don't know about the corporate level
because i never got to the point i
really tried but that's the only thing
they
they don't let you to go i don't know
how managers got to manage your studio
interesting
so you did not have a good experience
working for amazon no sir whatsoever but
by the way if you heard that strange
noise that was paul's stomach he's
hungry
that's what that sound was paul i caught
it paul looked at me as if i cut it or
not your stomach is growling
uh very interesting to hear that let me
get into the next part is it fair to say
that you like working at valuetainment a
little bit better than amazon
i'm in love with this job okay there we
go
by the way i noticed you took a break
let's make sure we write it up
vanessa you took us we love you we love
you
everybody everybody positive
but let's go back to it let's go back to
what they're saying here amazon has a
quota for the number of employees it
would
be happy to see leave each year wow
employees say there's a big reason
amazon's culture feels cutthroat
business insider one key piece of
amazon's
review process is a metric called
unregretted attrition rate ura which
represents
the percentage of employees managers
aren't sad to see leave the company
whether they part ways voluntarily
or otherwise even the most senior
executive at amazon including
uh incoming ceo andy jassy closely
tracks your according to the internal
documents uh obtained by insider jesse
for example has a
six percent goal for ura which means
he's expected to play six percent of his
team through
unregretted departures on what appears
to be annual basis the internal document
shows jazzy and other top
executives also kept track of the
current unregretted rate
a running tally of the percentage of
employees the company is not concerned
about losing and current gap to go which
is the number of employees it needs
to see leave each uh reach its targeted
ura adam i'll go to you
this is such a like i just thought
wow when i read this story because are
you familiar with the word attrition
this is basically essentially
losing business or losing employees and
i remember
you know being in the hospitality and
nightlife sector
in miami when i was in my 20s you have a
lot of turnover whether you're
you know it's a you're a bartender it's
your club a hotel
front desk you have a lot of turnover
it's a very high turnover type of
business
so you're constantly bringing on new
people it's sort of part of the game
and then when i got into financial sales
and financial services
something that i learned was attrition
like all right if you've got a hundred
companies you're working with or 100
agencies because i have a financial
wholesaler
you say look you're gonna your attrition
rate can go up year after year you
obviously want to keep people on
but you're naturally going to lose um
clients that's just sort of your
attrition rate so i'm familiar with this
word attrition i'm familiar with
turnover but this is a new term i've
never heard before bro
this is unregretted attrition rate
unregretted meaning
we don't give a f if they leave or or
stay
it's unregretted we don't give a [ __ ]
essentially if these people go in there
apparently their number
their goal is six percent so their
number
they put a number to it if i mean don't
be shocked by amazon using
using data and metrics their number
their magical number is six percent
where they're like look
if six out of 100 people leave or quit
or gone we're good with that
if it's ten percent twenty percent a
little too high for us but this is a
terminology i've never heard before you
are a unregretted attrition rate i've
heard something
i've said about it i'm not i'm i'm more
true you used to work at amazon as well
no but shout out to vanessa for
everything she's done but this
is we're learning i think let me let me
just slow it down for a second we are
learning more about
amazon i'm going to let him take over of
course we're going to let him take over
he's been taking over all day he's the
guest
birthday but this is a very new
terminology and amazon
doesn't i very i think i i no
i i know i think that uh
i think that they just put a name to
something that every company does
already anyway
i don't think i'm not surprised by it
i'm not offended by it
i'm not i'm not gonna like oh my god i
can't believe it
doesn't seem high at all though no it
doesn't but the reality is
i think that they just they just came up
with the terminology and metrics for
things that companies already do anyway
and it just they just shine the light on
a reality and emotional people that's
why they don't get very far because they
don't have to control their emotions
well look it's oh my god this is
horrible when in reality is
well what's your dating turnover rate
right do you have to like everybody you
date should you marry everybody
no people companies don't need a
marriage i'm with you 100 brother i
think what
we're in agreement here that yeah
there's turnover i talked about it in
hospitality
it's for me it's the unregretted
basically they don't like look is there
some people in your life that left that
you're so happy they left yeah of course
did you regret it
no i'm good with it i'm okay it's
unregretted
the fact that they put up their habits
behind the fact that they used they had
the audacity is what kind of blows you
down
in audacity is the fact that that's what
they called it they could have just
called it an
i'm good with that that's business okay
but then you have people like vanessa
that are that found a very a job she
absolutely loves to use her words right
versus a job okay
okay i'm regretted what was it
unregretted attrition right vanessa uh
did you regret leaving
absolutely so she didn't you you don't
regret leaving right
you don't girl leaving yeah no that's
what i'm saying i don't regret leaving
okay
so she's she's found her generally she
unregularly left
okay so it's over great on both sides so
a couple things let me agree here yeah
let me say a couple things to this story
here number one
uh when she says what she says about
amazon i have a lot of people that
also say they love working at amazon
i've also heard a lot of people tell me
they hate their managers
they love working for amazon they hate
their managers okay
i've heard that many many probably in a
lot of companies but what i'm trying to
tell you is like i'll go to a yard house
here okay the waitress here is not going
to be the same waitress as the waiter in
uh addison who took care of me jason i
missed you did you not miss jason
i'm missing jason jason is a guy you
know we're just so i'm going there
arnold palmer
pretty much the only reason i'd move
back to atticus for jason
it's it's
but here's the point so that's that
that's one part by the way i'm not
discounting vanessa had a bad experience
on amazon all i'm saying is
a manager can make a company look
terrible
if you don't track what some managers
are doing to their people i had a call
the other day
with the vps you were on the call when i
said moving forward look we're getting
some people that are
you know hey if you're going to abuse
and not do the right thing for your guys
we're going to get involved it's not
like hey it's okay no we're not
we're not gonna let that happen because
that's what makes a company look bad
a company sometimes looks bad because
they weren't able to inspect something
that was happening in one place believe
me i run a company and i see a lot of
the problems come up and sometimes like
man how come we didn't know about this
earlier
how come we didn't know about this
earlier this is so you have to reward
the people that are doing a good job
but stories like that happen all the
time as far as the six percent
uh uh uh ura that you're irate with and
i'm sorry to have you feel the way you
feel you seem very frustrated and i mean
your face is rare i don't know why
you're so upset about it this is what
ricky does i'm telling you
i think we need to bring something here
to kind of come uh adam's nervous
tells me we'll bring something in
that'll call mine but let me let me say
you're gonna bring the drinks again like
uh the martino
but anyways let me say this to you watch
this watch this adam
watch this six percent is amazons yeah
you know the legendary coo
who everybody wanted to emulate and they
swore by this guy books were written by
this guy everybody studied this guy
a guy named jack welch
said every year we have to fire the
bottom 10
of our employees and you know what
people said what a genius guy
this guy's a genius what a brilliant guy
we should do it as well
every year december 31st who's our
bottom 10 percent
i think joey made the cut billy made the
cut bobby made the cut
mary made the cut no mary's going in
there you got barry's down
here you guys are listening this didn't
work out we wish you nothing but the
very best we hope you have found a place
that's going to be better for you
and uh we want to give you one month
severance all the best you wish you
nothing but the best great boom you move
on right
people thought it was brilliant idea for
this to be done 70s 80s 90s but today
oh god forbid amazon says at 6
not even 10 you do that i i think it's
not a big deal and i applaud amazon for
doing it i think it's the right thing
they're doing i think the media is
spinning it again and they need somebody
to take shots at right now because
they're trying to force amazon to agree
did she did you see jeff bezos came out
you know i i agree with the raising of
the corporate taxes because companies
should be paying more in taxes
okay and they're kind of using him now
to say that because if he says it you
know it's okay kind of like how they use
buffett years ago when
buffett said it's okay i'm not paying
enough taxes
obama said if buffett said it and
everybody said well buffett said we've
got to vote for it
if biden if you know bezos says that we
got to go for it do you think pesos
is worried more about raising of
corporate taxes or do you think he's
more worried about
amazon being unionized of course he so
he's kind of sitting there looking
i say this on stage and i kind of tweet
this [ __ ] out and tell you like
but listen you cannot let me be
unionized if you're going to help me on
the union side
i'm willing to support you raising up
the taxes i don't care about paying a
little bit more because i want to make
my money on the other place anyway so
there's a lot of that speculation going
on on one end we got to trash
amazon to be able to you know get what
we want from them on the other end
amazon is also sitting there saying
leave me alone on the union you're not
unionizing side
but uh to each his own all i'm saying is
six percent's actually not a big deal
it's a reasonable number i thought for
sure
honestly i thought for sure amazon's
number would have been to 20
yeah not six percent yeah i'm not even
kidding with you i thought for sure
would have been a 20
number not a six percent which means
what a rewarding company they are
okay to be doing something what a nice
company it is
right yes sorry about your experience
not saying it didn't happen
because i've i've heard that before as
well but sometimes managers
is bad but for me and my entire
warehouse is bad
yeah no i hope it gets better fyi i
agree i was at an army unit
okay at an army unit my sergeants were
impeccable i loved my guys
but there were guys that came from
another unit same exact base fort
campbell kentucky came to 326
and they were bitching about their uh
sergeants that they had at this other
place at this other unit like you don't
even know what they do over there they
don't care about your health they don't
care about this they don't care about
that
they're true but it's not how army was
all
at the hunter first so we have to also
kind of keep that part of mind
you got something in mind are you trying
to say something yeah go ahead guys do
some two cents here so with
amazon i think uh because i actually
came from a warehouse background as well
in norway
you look like a warehouse you know shout
outs yeah
it's good i was gonna give him a shout
out but you know uh no sam did a great
job stepping in so that's for sure uh
but back to the warehouse
the challenge was every time i told him
to write something he wrote in spanish
i'm like just write down
every search he would do on google was
in spanish but go ahead guys so
so in warehouses in general uh because i
worked in one as well
and and it was the same issue kind of or
complaints that were mentioned by
vanessa's obviously
they logistics companies in general they
work on a very tight schedule they have
times shipments gotta go
if the truck leaves late you're losing
hundreds of thousands which accumulate
to millions
they said in traffic they lose millions
a year because things come late
it's a ripple effect right so i
understand that there's efficiency
and how they optimize it as much as
possible and at that point
unfortunately in many ways the weakest
link is the people not working fast
enough because you can
when you have thousands of employees and
they work one percent faster two percent
faster are you kidding me it's the book
toyota's way we read
toyota's wait three years ago this is
what it's all about toyota does that
mcdonald's does their speed on how
quickly they're able to do the fast food
this is business
it's accuracy i mean you got to be so
with in that sense that that could be a
lot of complaints because obviously you
want to find a balance of being as
efficient as possible but also not being
outright
disrespectful this that the other yeah
of course the nature of the game there
in that sense that you really can't do
anything about it
however uh would just add some two cents
on the
on them moving into uh moving into the
shopping centers nothing about you is
two cents you're always a nickel but go
ahead you're a little bit more than two
cents
go ahead uh so so what this does is this
gives them a high
point we've been waiting i'll tell you
adam just wait and see here
so with amazon moving in there you
with amazon moving into malls they're
now moving into the last mile
uh delivering so now they're they're
closer to americans
because with walmart they're super
centers everywhere
they're with what is within 10 miles
do you think they would ever turn these
what do you think they're doing this is
to be able to compete with this move is
exactly to be able to compete for
retail like to walk into an amazon store
like you would walk away i don't know
about that
jeff bezos multiple times he'll only do
it if they can do something new which
they did with the uh he will he will
eventually do it
will eventually do because listen
sitting at home you're going to be bored
out of your mind eventually you got to
get out and do some stuff you got to see
some people outside yeah i actually have
a house in a year so i understand i i
need to get out more often
anything so the only they're go stores
which they have some places where
you don't have to do the cash register
you just go in you grab what you want
the cameras take picture they charge it
to your amazon account why don't we
leave so this pissed off somebody can we
show this anti-capitalist trying to
climb the jp morgan chase building and
see what happened to him because i think
ricky's really curious to know what
happens to this guy
yeah i i saw it but i don't know what i
don't i didn't i didn't really follow so
here here's a a gentleman who
decides to climb the wall do you have it
or no watch this here so
watch this this is they're spraying
jp morgan chase's building
[Music]
is this in new york where is this
addison
house texas no no this is new york
[Music]
watch
first of all good for him so far so far
he's looking good
[Music]
all right buddy it's about to get
interesting in about seven seconds
six five four
three two one
oh my gosh oh my gosh
[Music]
oh my gosh that's not blood by the way
it looks like blood it's not blood it's
ink
no that's how antifa bleeds black blood
wow it's a pretty bad situation
okay press pause uh
ricky thoughts god oh my god
you know um
i got a lot of thoughts about it i think
that uh i think a lot of people
were so we're so spoiled here that
that people don't that people don't
understand these anti-capitalist
socialist people don't understand how
bad other countries have it
and they come here and they want to do
these stupid little protests like this
um by the way you know how many how many
i mean
how many how many cars have been bought
by people they couldn't afford them cash
that chase funded they gave him a loan
how many businesses hasn't been started
because of chase how many houses have
not been bought because of chase
i mean it's just crazy to think that
people would actually go against a a a
corporation that literally allows you to
fund your dream well if your dream is to
own your first car
chase will fund it your dream is owned a
business chase will fund it
you know obviously you have to fall fall
into some requirements you want to own a
home chase will fund it
it's crazy how uh people would
literally want to bite the hand that
feeds them it's it's amazing to me
um but you know it's uh these these
socialists
people with social socialist ideas are
just man they're a special breed
adam what do you want to say about this
i mean uh i mean i have a huge a lot of
respect for jamie dimon the ceo
of jpmorgan chase and um that guy's an
idiot and uh you're gonna
scale a wall or scale a uh a building
and
i mean i hope he's got a good health
insurance hopefully maybe he's on
obamacare
i think some i think these people pat
you know what we got to do to them
we need to give them a one-way ticket to
whatever country that has socialism that
they
like like i would love to start that
that that foundation
you know the the one would be called the
one-way foundation you want to send them
to venezuela wherever they want to go
except here yes go to scandinavia
wherever you think the socialist country
is
let's send you over there i mean if it's
so great right in america so evil just
go
give us go uh we'll have you jump on the
plane we'll have
uh the flight attendant retrieve your
passport and then just uh just take off
just take off and then we'll make sure
we call the embassy all down there let
them know that you don't need another
passport because you have no intention
of coming back to such an evil country
right to say to this evil empire right
just go
just take off we don't need you here i
mean people like that obviously do not
are not are not uh they are not
engaging in any type of transaction that
makes anybody money
right because they're they're
anti-capitalists so they're they're
costing the country more
money money more than their uh than
they're they're they're creating
so they they don't know business here
let's talk about the olympics let's talk
about the olympics here in close
constellations with partners and allied
around the world baydeman
administration will weigh 2022 beijing
games for us this is associated press
story the state department said tuesday
the biden administration is consulting
with allies about a joint approach to
china and its human rights record
including how to handle
the upcoming beijing winter olympics
human rights groups are protesting
china's
hosting of the games which are set to
start in february 2022
they have urged a diplomatic or
straight-up boycott of the event to call
attention to alleged chinese abuse
against
uh against uh uh tibetans and residents
of hong kong
the beijing winter olympics opened
february uh for 2022 to china
and china is denied all charge of human
rights abuses it says political motives
underlie the boycott efforts both the
internal olympics
committee and the u.s olympic and uh
paralympic
committee have said in the past a po
they oppose boycotts
thoughts yeah well i think number one
there's two there's two sides to this
um china is uh committing
human rights uh atrocities against the
uyghurs
and i guess tibetans as well but i think
that everything is going on in the
uyghurs which is basically the west
the west side of china uh west side
where rick is from
that is a true thing that's going on
there is human right abuses going on in
china
it is happening but if i'm biden or if
i'm the bide administration i have to
have a
bigger perspective here and win the war
not the battle
battling over whether or not we should
compete in the olympics
is bs to me it's like that's not where
you should be fighting
uh your battle here we have a massive
situation going on with china with the
trade war and everything that's going on
and tariffs and everything
and everything that's associated with
china and competing for the top spot in
the economy
this is not the place that we want to
have
um the the war go down over the freaking
olympics so
pick and choose your battles if you're
biden and yes they are
committing human rights atrocities that
is true
no fan of china and what they're doing
but this is the stage
to basically voice your concerns that's
my opinion do you boycott or do not
boycott i do not boycott no no no
not meaning america should we keep
olympics in china beijing 2022
yes we should yes and people around the
world should comfortably go to china
because even the coronavirus has been
documented that came out of wuhan
three years later if this is if this is
where
um if this is where the olympics is
scheduled
yeah is this the winter olympics yes the
winter olympics so
something that i've come to terms with
is multilateralism over unilateralism
if multiple countries if nato comes out
or
and if a whole of a squad of countries
and says
look we're the eu we're australia we're
canada we're united states
we're this this this and this and we're
all coming together and saying uh uh uh
uh uh
but to go at it alone unilateralism
which trump sort of coined
that is not the look that i want biden
doing so if a collective effort says
this is what we are
all doing i'm in favor of that going at
it alone against china
who who right now is it kai who right
now is against it
who's right now against it about having
the winter olympics in china
ricky do you have any thoughts on this
um you know i'm kind of i'm kind of torn
pat when it comes on to this because
i i think that what ends up happening is
that you know i
i have a lot of friends that are chinese
right and you know
they're good people you know they're not
bad people these are people that are
very loving and
um smart smart individuals and uh as a
as a country you know i
i don't know if you do you do or what do
i guess what we're trying to do is
who are we punishing by boycotting it
the
the people or the country or the
government i mean we're do by by
boycotting this
we're we're saying that we don't agree
with something so what is it that we
don't agree with i mean how are we so
comfortable taking other material
why are we comfortable uh buying other
stuff for a cheap rate
now you don't want to host the olympics
for the biggest distributor of goods in
the world
i mean that's kind of contradicting
right uh we haven't
we the trade war that we won uh by the
way we didn't win
i'm sorry we won the trade war we didn't
win the trade war
trump didn't want to work there's anyone
winning trump didn't win the trade war
no he didn't okay that's not the
conversation
i don't think there's been any winners
in this i'm gonna stick to pat's
conversation
so the question becomes we're okay doing
business with them we're okay taking
their stuff we're okay having our
things made over there but now you want
to boycott the olympics kind of crazy to
me i mean i don't like a communist
country anymore than anybody else does
but
uh i think it's contradicting as much
dealings as he has and his son has
with china which are recorded him being
a what is a ceo cfo or chairman of one
of the
uh chinese companies that paid them i
don't know how many millions of dollars
now you want to go act like you're mad
at them
i'm not with them bro you know pick a
side and stick to it
to me it's a couple different things to
me one it's i don't know
about you know maybe we flip
and give somebody spot for 2022 and let
the world
calm down with china for a decade before
we bring olympics back to them
i think it's a little too sensitive it's
it's a it's like
you know it's like a divorce that
happens and
christmas is around the corner and you
still expect the mom and dad and
everybody to come together and have
spend christmas together it's just it's
a little fresh it's a little fresh for
us to do it
let's give a little bit of time to get
everybody come together maybe a year
from now
we'll come back and do this we just had
the world shut down because of china
let's face it that's true we had the
world shut down because of one country's
lack of responsibility that somehow some
way a virus comes out of there and the
world takes a hit because of it
economy jobs restaurants lives
people loved ones careers
well all this stuff that's happened the
last 12 months because of
one country and yet we want to keep it
there for 2022.
i'm not saying we permanently boycott it
i say you need a couple years give it a
couple of seasons
i want to postpone them i don't want to
postpone the olympics because it is
unfair for the athlete listen
you know i watch uh when i see like when
you were telling me the story the other
day
you told the story to me i took the
story in a different way because i
looked at you as my son not that you're
my son we're two years apart
when he told a story about you know you
uh when the way adrian said it he was
emotional because of how much he loves
you he said
look we're living in colorado adam wants
to make a career and being a comedian
he wants to go out there and be a
comedian and wants to make it into the
nba so he's going out to playing ball
all this other stuff he starts playing
basketball with these guys that are
denver nuggets guys then they say
there's an open tryout
it's a d league whatever the league was
for you to come through so the same day
you're gonna go to the triad you tell
adrian look just come and pick me up at
nine o'clock
i got a flight at one o'clock my dad's
paying a flight i haven't seen this guy
for four years i'm gonna go to vegas and
spend time with him right the story
you're telling
so i'm just kind of really curious with
the story so haven't seen pops for a few
years you're going to go see him in
vegas your dad's obviously not here with
us today but you're going to go see him
in vegas
and uh but you're not like i'm not going
to make it to the nba let's face it i'm
just going in there seeing what happens
so you go
and then you text adrian like dude you
won't believe it i made it past the
first round okay
and what are you talking about yeah i'm
going to the next one so pick me up at
10 o'clock
and then you go and you play you're
killing it and you make the second cut
dude what are you talking about dude i'm
still not gonna make it just pick me up
at 11 o'clock
you're going you make it past the third
oh just pick me up at the fourth you
know fourth
you and you make it past fourth you
throw some labs
dunks all this stuff that's happening
visually he's selling it to me on what
happened to it
and then finally you're one cut away
shaun chauncey billup's nephew
apparently made it i don't know who the
you know he made cousin makes it and uh
it could have been you you're one cut
away from playing for being on a roster
of the uh
denver nuggets having your own base
basketball card adam sussman okay
and then all of a sudden you run out and
you say i can't do it you're running out
to go see your dad
you chose that over your sport you're
running after you see kiki van
even the way yeah he says kid what are
you doing you can actually have a shot
it says listen i'd love to do anything
with the denver organization here's
give me your number you exchange numbers
you get on the flight you go to vegas
just to see your dad and your dad says
what what are you doing you should have
gone to the tryouts right but you wanted
to go spend time with your dad so
what's the moral of the story these kids
have been training for years to go to
the olympics we cannot punish them yes
it is not fair to punish the people that
have been training they're at the
parents that took the kids to tryouts
to practice the endless hours of clothes
driving them traveling the investment
it's a lot of pain
so the athlete cannot take the hit so we
can't cancel it
we simply have to relocate it to a
different place but we have to tell
china
listen it's sensitive right now it is
sensitive right now
we're not canceling you we are
postponing you
let's let the dust settle we'll come
back 10 years from now
and consider giving you the next slot
when it opens up maybe in 2026
but just not in 2022 so let's pick a
place
that's done this before salt lake city
utah let's pick a place there's plenty
of places that have done the winter
olympics before
pick a country maybe it's the last on
the list bring them up right now that's
20 years from now give them that slot
and then let's give them some of the
commerce that people trust a little bit
more that they've handled
coveted maybe better than some other
countries happening let's go over there
okay let's go over there and by the way
then the challenge even becomes some
countries that don't even want the
olympics to come to them
japan may say we've done this all right
i don't even want you to come to us i
get of course and i don't blame them but
you have a pool of countries that would
say
we'll take it i guarantee you there's 10
countries that would love to take them
i guarantee you salt lake city may sit
there and say look if you want to come
out here we'll figure it out if you want
to go to
new york and you want to go to what
what's that city of uh in new york where
they
practice uh lake placid yeah lake placid
there is options i just think it's
sensitive there's one group that i i've
been to lake placid the whole illusion
place i've been there before
the one community that cannot take a hit
is the kids
the athletes yeah the parents for it
it's so emotional man
yeah it is so emotional so because we
don't know if they'll make the cut to
make sure that
exactly yeah it's four years four years
a long time it's a once-in-a-lifetime
type of thing
exactly exactly so anyways we'll see
what's going to happen with that but
that's my thoughts but by far
spider doesn't have a history of caring
about people in
any way so it doesn't really matter
don't offend at him like that i don't
just
to chime in i wholeheartedly agree with
you yeah it's a great story i i totally
it's your story
thank you i appreciate that um one cut
away from the nugget summer league team
um but if if we do do this it needs to
be a collective decision biden can't be
the one making this decision
and something tells me that i don't
think it's gonna i don't think it's
gonna happen china does need to pay a
price
but by the way there was just a report
that just came out
w.h.o i don't know how much you how much
stock you put into them
they came out and they said there's a
very very high likelihood
that the covet 19 virus came from
the wet market not a lab thoughts
do we really want to go there buddy i
just want to know your thoughts i mean
first of all
who who who funds uh the world health
organization we do
that's why i well no china does not us
they're number one we're number two
right and
trump even pulled out right i don't
quote unquote independent report i don't
know we'll find the i mean kai maybe you
can find the report
i just want to know that i would love if
china wants us to
really believe that i would love open up
social media
give freedom of speech let people go in
there and investigate
from both sides of the aisle let us send
some independent researchers there
and talk to the folks and see what we
can investigate until that happens
i don't believe any stories that comes
out that's where i stand with i don't
care if it's world health organization
cdc i don't care if it's
anything abc i'm not buying it i'm
buying an
independent organization from both sides
of the aisle
that goes in august do you know what's
the biggest change you know how you said
you know 50 of republican men don't want
to take the vaccine
why don't they let's ask the question
why don't they want to take it why why
don't why don't fifty percent of
uh my word is distrust probably okay so
where does this trust come from
where does this trust come from being
screwed over him i don't think it's
screwed over no i don't even think it's
screwed over you know where my distrust
comes from
let me tell you where my distress comes
from here's where my distress comes from
if somebody's watching this right now
people say you know adam soy boy adam
this or adam dad
dude i love talking to people who are
opposing companions it's my favorite
people to t
you're respectful you're amicable we can
sit down we can have a conversation and
we enjoy it and we go on and it's great
vanessa's here she gave her opinions i
don't care if she agrees or disagrees
i love having her here we have that kind
of an environment it's a safe space for
us to have opposing views clash
who learns god willing the audience says
right today's session was great i don't
know about that i don't know about that
i bet somebody today's saying dude you
got to go watch that immigration debate
so you're learning right here's the
problem why half of republican men
that you're saying don't want to take
the vaccine because the opposing
argument has no voice today yeah
i the opposing argument has been
vilified i contact paul offit
to say why don't you come and do a
debate with somebody else that has an
argument on the other side for vaccine
i contact all these guys you know what's
the first thing they say no i'll give
you 10 grand
no i'll give you 20 000 i don't
know so so even when
the the the uh what do you call it the
fair is taking place
and uh robert de niro is at that one
fair and he's like hey you know the
movie festival
and the vax thing got pulled the day
before well we just decided it wasn't
something that we wanted to do and
robert was like why you should watch
this it's actually good silenced right
when an opposing argument is silent
silenced
you lose credibility yes so for me when
that is taking place
i have a problem with that okay so when
you're going back and saying what do you
think about world health organizations
saying this this that it came from a
you know a wet market not the lap i'm
hearing one argument
allow the other side to go do their own
investigation and then let us
the audience go through the arguments
and see who we want to believe
let us do it not you yeah no i agree
with you i think
i think that you know going back to what
pat said is uh you know
when when when you're you know when
you're canceling the president united
states the one that actually
helped create the vaccine i'm noticing
that you're more of a community guy
you're not more of a you don't believe
in leadership too much
right you believe that communities i
believe in communities too but you know
i'm a big believer in leadership that
leaders are the ones that drive things
obviously because i lead an organization
i should you know
leave one of the best teams in the
company and i'm very blessed to say that
because i'm honored to work
beside professionals that are all
leaders um
you know i i think that uh that uh when
it comes down to
a subject like this um we have to
we have to really take a step back and
in
and analyze the whole thing right for
example what's your opinion on it when
it comes down to what pat was saying
what's your overall opinion on it on
whether the
cobot was created in the lab yeah in the
wet market the bottom line is we don't
know but i'm trusting
no no hold on hold on but i think i
think there's a high likelihood that it
came from this wet market okay travel
through animal through a bat
but am i dismissing the fact that china
probably did something no doubt china
covered it up right no doubt
okay that's not we're not even gonna
okay play that game china covered it up
they didn't let the world know this was
happening
they didn't shut down airports so so
they kept it under wraps right
was it created in the lab i don't know
pat said one time something very
interesting
he says when somebody goes too hard the
other side
the consequence is going to rebound the
other way yeah right so
so for example he says uh uh uh uh he
said a clinton
created a bush a bush created in obama
and obama
created uh created a uh uh uh
a biden yeah but abiding was pushing so
hard so fast that he's
he's you know these other guys suddenly
did it like trump didn't he was not
subtle about
him pushing people back neither is biden
so you know so he's pushing so hard that
we just have a huge distrust
uh first of all because he's he's
he's made comments and racist comments
before which they're documented
he you know called the certain community
uh you know
uh predators and then locked them up
like there's so much distrust with him
and everything that he says
that it has nothing to do with this
place has nothing to do with the vaccine
and everything to do with
him uh we don't if if trump created the
vaccine
what does that have what does that have
to do with bite no no i get that but you
don't believe that though because you
just said it's a community
you said a community you got to make a
choice on what you believe so so
okay so you're you're you're you're
crisscrossing here it's about you
gave trump props for creating the
vaccine yes but now you're saying we
don't trust biden because he's
distributing the vaccine right
so which one is it no no i i agree with
you the thing is with me is
the i i will not take that vaccine okay
and as you distrust i just no because i
distrust the government period
okay right because they've lied to us
multiple times they've covered things up
for four years you don't understand i'm
not a totalitarian when it comes down to
that with trump
i already i told you earlier i i like a
lot of things that he did it doesn't
mean i fully agree with him
right i don't agree with the vaccine now
do the same
but hold on though but do i understand
that he had a responsibility
to the world to come up with the vaccine
yes because the rest of the world are
scared
he needed to find a solution for the
people that are scared do i fully
believe that he thinks that that was
the proper solution no but he could he
could have come out and say it
no he couldn't come out and say you
don't need a vaccine you're going to be
all right he can't do that as a world
leader
he can't do that so therefore us that
are
that we support what he stood for
we can we can we can read between the
lines and understand that he has a job
to do
but this is one of the things that we're
just not gonna go with
i don't know if that makes sense what
i'm saying or not does it make sense or
not did i confuse you
or did it make sense we know that
argument no no i'm asking you
no i'm with you we're good so we know
how to read between the lines okay
as a world leader he needed to do
something like that right because
everybody else was going to follow
okay it doesn't mean that us don't know
how to read between another we don't we
just
stress i don't i just anything that the
binding administration touches i don't
trust it i don't care what it is
if they blink too many times i don't
trust them i just don't i just
you know oh we're not going to tax the
middle class not the deal
if i said the same thing about trump
anything that trump does i just trust
anything he does i just trust that's
fine bro
do i am i fair to say because i i've
never said that but you're going to
do you're going very far right no no i'm
not going you're disgusting no there's
anything
everything has been lies everything's
been alive how do you want something bro
it's like it's like having a dog bite
you multiple times
when before you when it's in the in the
kennel
right and you're getting ready to uh to
to uh to
adopt it and then you're surprised when
it bites you when you adopted him okay
the dogs bit many times already many
times in
in every category that you can imagine
right he was uh
side by side with robert byrd which oh i
left the kkk
no is that after lbj it was not okay to
be a racist bro
so you had to switch in order to vote it
in you didn't leave the kkk
you just wrote a book about leaving the
king how you regretted it because we
were progressing into a world where
being part of the kkk and racism was no
longer acceptable
robert byrd senator robert byrd the one
that died and they give it obama and
clinton he'll give him a standard
ovation
right he was a uh he was in the kkk
openly kkk right but as the time
progresses lbj
with the great society act which
literally single-handedly caused
uh father absence in the minority
community
uh you cannot all excuse where we want
to help no you don't want to help you
want to enslave
and you want to break the core of the
family foundation
so i just don't trust them bro it's just
years of lies and
and coming in and undoing and look at
our border look at
the things that's going on with kovalev
he's not going to the border right
and it's a crisis he's lying about the
taxes what am i supposed to do sit here
and trust me that he says
i just can't bro okay so you distrust
anything that he does fairness
let me read this to you by what happened
with taina and china china taiwan
accused china of trying to bribe
paraguay with kobe 19 vaccines to make
it stop
recognizing taiwan this is a story from
business insider
paraguay is one of the 15 nations that
still recognize taiwan as independent
and it is in dire need of vaccines china
has
long insisted that taiwan is part of
china though taiwan has operated as its
own country for decades on wednesday
joseph wu
taiwan's foreign minister said that
china has sought to use the turmoil
to pressure paraguay into swearing
publicly that taiwan was part of china
he said the chinese government was very
active in saying
if the paraguay government's government
is willing to severe
diplomatic ties with taiwan they will be
able to get a quite a few million
vaccine doses from china let me say this
one more time the chinese government was
very active in saying that if paraguay
government
is willing to sever diplomatic ties with
taiwan they will be able to get
quite a few million vaccine doses from
china he went on to say that the
taiwanese government had reached out to
japan the us and india to ask for
vaccines
in an attempt to bat away from beijing's
advances last month china's foreign
minister
ministries said it was providing 69
countries with free vaccines and it was
selling vaccines to 28 nations
uh look i mean these guys are just
pushing people around and half these
stories you really like is it true is it
not true you're probably leaning towards
what yeah it's probably true
and then the tesla story with china let
me just bring it all together uh go to
page five with the tesla store yeah the
cameras
yeah so now they are saying that uh
tesla is doing what and tesla comes back
and says listen we want to reassure you
that china the cameras in its cars are
turned off this a fox business story
tesla has taken
to social media to ensure customers in
the country that the cameras installed
in their cars are turned off all teslas
have eight external cameras
that are primarily for their driving
assist features but can also
record video while the model 3 and model
y have also camera installed near the
rear view mirror
that can monitor the cab and it was
reported in march that tesla has been
banned from chinese military complexes
due to spying concerns
tesla has begun to use the interior
camera in north america to gather data
on driver's awareness
related to the use of its full
self-driving features ilama said that
the several
early access data beta testers were
barred
of access to the latest version of the
software for not paying
sufficient attention to the road they
are so paranoid
okay they want control control control
and they don't want others to do to them
what they're doing to the other nations
it's so interesting they want to spy on
everybody else but they don't want it to
happen to them and they know when you're
doing it to them
very interesting culture that they have
there but tesla's gonna play ball i mean
they're not gonna
they're they're eager to obviously get
into china and sell their cars there so
i i elon musk is gonna who's a true
capitalist i applaud elon for everything
sure but if he's gonna get to china and
try to make some money he's gonna play
by their rules don't you think
yeah uh uh you know yes absolutely and
um
absolutely i agree with you there we're
gonna see what's gonna happen with those
guys on the
story hey uh what's uh what's uh um
uh uh uh man let me see this here
um uh give me a second here we go ricky
while we're waiting
tell just in general how you feeling now
you're 33 now
you're here in florida you're here for
how long oh i'll be glad to see
that's it you're in you're out you're in
your round
33 years old yesterday yes 33 years
pretty crazy man
pretty crazy so 33 years old yesterday
what are you doing to celebrate for your
birthday bro
what are you doing
[Music]
foreign
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
happy birthday to you
[Music]
is
erica just text me i ask erica what's
ricky's favorite mariachi song she said
el rey
i don't know what el rey is but there we
go okay
[Music]
foreign
is
[Music]
a
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay ricky what are you gonna wish for
oh it's gonna be for you what are you
gonna wish for bro hopefully one day
adam comes to the senses
i don't think so ricky i don't think
did you expect no i didn't know those
guys
i had no idea they had mariachi in
florida
you know there's a lot of mexicans down
here support them bro yeah i know yeah
they got no kidding
they came across the border it's easier
these days you are so
funny uh thank you guys so much i
appreciate it man you guys have no idea
how much i appreciate that's so freaking
big
birthday buddy thank you i appreciate it
it's so awesome again gang if you're
following this we put the instagram
account of ricky below go
follow him give him some love uh if you
enjoyed the discourse that we had today
make sure you do that um look i mean we
got a lot of different topics to choose
right now to wrap up with
a lot of them let's give a shout out to
kim kardashian finally being a
billionaire right kim kardashian shout
out for being a billionaire
uh uh you know adam i think more for you
you've spent some time with her what do
you think about her becoming a
billionaire now kim kardashian
officially
uh wow congratulations kim uh we
you know i've hung out with kim a lot
i've hung out with your future governor
bruce jenner caitlyn jenner a lot
and she's a classy gal i mean she i mean
she's more than anything gonna influence
all those instagram
models you know there's hope for you too
ladies you can twerk your way to the top
no problem whether it's a sex tape
whether it's business
whether it's social media good for you
i'm just saying we're stating facts here
so congratulations kim yeah got nothing
but love for you girl
yeah you know i i'm gonna be honest with
you as far as how they started i'm not a
fan of that
i think it's a bad example to women but
but however
i will have to say that congratulations
to her and her family for capitalizing
on it
right they didn't just they didn't just
live that 15 minute of fame
uh they were actually they're able they
were actually able to create an empire
so
uh you know like i said i'm not fond of
it because of how they started i don't
want my daughters to ever look up to
that example
but as far as what she was able to do
and look becoming a billionaire
becoming a millionaire is not easy let
alone a billionaire that takes strategy
that takes making the right decisions
that takes you know it it's a whole
different level of mindset so for her to
be able to do that congratulations to
her and her family
no doubt before i forget in honor of
ricky's birthday mickey's birthday
is it mickey's it's also mickey's
birthday
mickey happy birthday quick shout out to
obviously valuetainment but tambien
valuetainment espanol it's a new channel
that we lost
that's true i know you might have uh
some uh some say on that channel
yeah but shout out to our friend eric
kikigalera who's
heading up the uh the channel with that
but shout out to valuetainment espanol
if you speak spanish and you want to see
pat speak spanish on entrepreneurship
so all the content's being translated
into spanish and shout out to eric he's
doing a phenomenal job eric's doing a
phenomenal job on a lot of different
ends i'm a big fan of eric
yes uh his level of work ethic right now
former marine the guy's kicking some
major tale
proud of leo roy those guys what they're
doing but valuetainment spanish
uh we may be having ricky have a uh
uh do something with vitamin spanish we
have the conversation together you and i
we're women when we talk to people were
we in hawaii
i think we were in hawaii we weren't we
talked about that so it's going to be
exciting to see what happens
i'm so excited but having set that gang
it's coming close to 11 o'clock uh
here's what i may do next week i may do
next week on tuesday okay
i mean i don't even know if the building
is going to be okay with this but i may
do next two
next tuesday i may reveal the bike i
just bought oh my god
bring it up here so if you haven't seen
it yet it's a red
i went i've been this week and i just i
got i better show it to you but when you
see it it's freaking what time's your
flight today
that's all five okay so if i go there
you know what we may
i may even take you to show a couple
homes that we're looking at yeah we got
time yeah we got time
shoot your flight's at five yeah okay so
i can't show you the bike but i'll
okay we'll do so we'll talk about what
we're gonna do with that but anyways
next tuesday
you may want to join the podcast because
i may pull up the entire bike here we're
going to bring the camera on to see it
listen
it is so ridiculous how beautiful this
bike is i can't i mean you were the
first person that saw it yeah i was
there when you bought it it's a red
is it just swiped his credit cards
yeah just put it right in the car but
when you see the bike it's they're
beautiful
it's sexy it's gorgeous it's beautiful
and it'll be revealed
next tuesday and uh that bike kardashian
do have a lot of similarities if you
know what i'm talking about
well this one is more on the road yeah
and then we'll see i mean
we're gonna we will definitely take
different angles for you to be pleased
with that
but there's a bigger surprise there's a
bigger surprise after that which
which will be it's pretty crazy ricky
what's going on but anyway reveal any of
that no
no no no no next tuesday don't miss the
podcast because i'm going to put it
right there
and we'll show the whole thing next
tuesday haven't said that ricky
thanks for coming out really enjoyed
this
so let's meet somewhere in the middle
we'll see you guys next tuesday if you
enjoyed it
subscribe and click that notification
button take care everybody
you